Hello, hello everyone!
If I sound tired right now, it is because it's 5 in the
morning.
Now some of you might be wondering, why the fuck are you
streaming at 5 in the morning?
And also, didn't you say you were gonna take a three-day
break?
to get the Jeff's business skin.
So I was like, I'm going to play a couple of games because I
really, really want to play, get the Jeff skin.
And then, you know, the last game I played, I got flamed by
two pro players on my team.
And now I feel petty as fuck because they think they can
flame me when I'm not streaming.
I had so I cried by the way right after I started crying
right after but I'm okay now I'm I feel now I'm feeling they
think they think that oh I'll stop queuing and I'll stop
terrorizing their fucking games I did cry but I'm back I'm
back though I'm but I came back because I was like You think
that's the last you'll see of me?
I'm gonna keep going.
And because you can't avoid me forever.
I hope I get on your team again.
So I just feel sort of very petty right now.
The thing is, I made, okay, I would say I did make mistakes
in the beginning of the game.
Like the first half of the game, I made mistakes, but then
the second half.
I didn't fuck up, but they kept blaming me like I was just
like bro Okay, I would admit that I did make like a mistake
that caused us like the last fight But then they kept
flaming me like not only in like in Matt like they're like
Gee, geez, we might as well forfeit because she's on our
team I was like bro.
What the fuck like I was just like My what my mistake cannot
mean that I sabotaged the entire game like so yeah and then
and because and I was like bro what the fuck and then so so
also like obviously streaming always makes me feel better so
that's why I'm doing that too also by the way it didn't help
that right after that game after I started like when I was
done crying um um I got my period so I was just like oh
that's why
Now I get it.
So it's much more, it's more, it's even more justified as to
why I'm very petty right now.
So, and a classic women moment, you know.
So yeah, that's why I chose to do.
Now it's more justification as to why I chose to do this
instead of sleeping it off.
So anyway, anyway, after, after that, they, he, and then
like, they kept flaming me, it's because I checked out their
stream, I was like, wait, I, because I recognized these
players, so I, like, checked out their stream because they
were streaming, and then they proceed to fucking continue to
flame me, like, to their chats, looking at my stats for that
game, I'm like, bro, fuck you.
And so like, that's why I'm now I'm here.
Because I was like, you can't avoid me forever.
You think just because you made me cry.
Just because you made me cry.
That I will stop queuing.
Yes, but it was only temporary.
But now I'm back.
I'm fucking back.
Also, I'm testing out my soundproof too.
I'm testing out my soundproof as well.
It's good timing.
Because I haven't tested it.
yet i haven't tested out um that's right i am an e-o-m agent
and i will fucking terrorize these lobbies i'm back baby i'm
let your anger feel you so no they were just they were
actual they were just they were assholes man i was just like
bro what the i was just like bro like fuck off Like, the
fact that they just kept going at it, too.
I was just like, bro, fuck off.
It's 5 in the morning.
Okay, it was 4 in the morning when it happened.
I was like, bro, you're playing Rink at 4 in the fucking
morning.
I just wanted the Jeffskin.
So, yes, so am I.
But, like, you should not be expecting top performance.
at four in the morning.
You should know what you're getting at four in the morning.
And if they are on East Coast, you should know what you're
getting at seven in the morning.
Like what type of games you're getting at that time.
You should know.
Like I've accepted what lobbies I'm getting at this time.
What type of idiots queuing at seven in the morning.
so um so that's why i have a lot of adrenaline right now uh
going okay now now i have adrenaline again because i'm
thinking back about that game i had um i thought back like
the the anger and my and and women problems coming at me
right now uh yeah on a on a monday i also yes you're right a
fucking Monday you should know what games you're getting so
um um so anyway that's why I'm um uh that's why I'm I'm here
right now so I'm not gonna call out the names but if they
start flaming me again if we pump into it and they start
flaming me again I don't need to call anyone out That's
that's that's on them.
They show themselves on my stream.
Anyway, now that's thank you for gifting a tier one sub.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Red dust.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
My ever since I cleaned my go XLR, the the button to mute
myself.
um is like super wonky for some reason like i have to press
it like three times for it to mute that's why i also wanted
to stream too because i'm like if anyone's gonna flame me
i'm making content out of it like this i'm not being flamed
for free like i was just like bro what the fuck if i'm
getting flamed i might as well i might as well stream i'm
not getting flamed for free Like, all I did, all I wanted,
all I wanted was this Jeff skin.
That's all I wanted.
Anyway, also, because you guys can see that I have a lot of
units, I ended up giving up and just exchanging it for,
like, after I got famed, I was like, this isn't worth it.
So I started, I just, I exchanged my, because you can
exchange your units, you can exchange it for your units.
with um with the coin so i was just like this isn't worth it
i'm just i'm just gonna oh yes i got another shirt i'm just
gonna use the units because i have so much anyway um yeah i
was like exchange exchange getting i was like this is not
worth it i just gonna do this all right nice It's so cute,
though.
Look how cute he is.
I also, like, I haven't played Rivals since, like, the...
Like, I did play...
I know you guys saw me tweet about DPS, but, like, I haven't
played, like, high-elow Rivals since the anniversary update.
So, um...
I don't know.
I love his business.
Oh, my God.
He could be, like, casual, Jeff, though.
Also, Quantum, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Oh, subs, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, it's a tail.
Oh, it's like ID.
cards okay he could have what's this oh like a little
sticker okay i like the id cards i think that oh i like the
sticky notes i think default is the best one oh my god oh
it's so cute and he has the usb the usb cord too on his it's
so cute i love this skin so much anyway by the way for those
who were like i went to time square and like where was that
thing you were talking about
if you're like where are you talking about doki oh if you
know you know yeah so it wasn't apparently wasn't like on
the anniversary day it was actually like on the exact rival
day so in four days make sure you're at time square guys
make sure you're there alright alright let's queue up let's
queue up oh yeah um i bought i bought this skin too because
of because of this with the tutu let's go this cheers me up
too this brings me joy yeah this is the i mean like i have
so much i met as well like no i think they buffed it because
they made it shinier I'm pretty sure Taka Thank you for the
five gifted subs Thank you Thank you Yeah they definitely
buffed it by making it shine here I love the tweet where
someone was like If I lose to a venom Who has this skin on
and the MVP Screenplays I'm gonna find where he lives And
change the trajectory of his life forever
People apparently people did not want to lose to a venom
with the skin people were wondering like oh why is that
what's wrong with this why do people not want to lose to the
skin um well it's because the MVP let me show you guys is
all right where was it let me see the MVP is is this this is
the MVP
so people were like I will find where they live and change
the trajectory of its life forever or I will uninstall the
game so that's why people were like I do not want to lose to
this skin anyway oh we can finally roleplay I like how they
made this to kick all the roleplay players out don't worry
guys i'm here to roleplay hello everyone hello guys oh my
gosh apparently when the game for when um this first came
out this game mode came out for like the um for everyone
else because you know how i i was able to have like early
access to it where is it where's the subway station so i
don't know i don't know how to actually do it i think it was
like go ask jeff and then swap the penny but let's find the
subway station where the fuck is the subway station guys
yeah oh by the way the funco pop store is here now this is
actually not only do we have hot topic we now have the funco
pop shop that's crazy i know apparently had they added
funcos now oh my god oh my god funco i'm wondering how are
they going First off, aren't they going bankrupt?
How do they have the funds to put themselves in Marvel
Rivals?
Like...
Alright, where's the subway station?
I'm trying to find that right now.
Guys, where's...
Do you guys know where the subway station is?
Because I don't remember.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is the...
How... As a New Yorker, how do you even...
Where do you go?
Where the fuck do you go as a New Yorker?
worker.
Oh, it was next to the Funko Shop.
Oh my god, clearly I'm not very good in New York.
My RP is so bad.
Minus one RP.
I can't.
I don't know how to get to the subway station.
All right, so apparently, wait, this is the subway.
Wait, what?
Where the fuck is the subway station?
What?
There's no subway station at the Funko Shop.
Oh, never find out, I guess.
Yeah, that's a bus stop.
That ain't no.
That's a bus stop, guys.
Okay, so, okay.
Actually, I won't spoil it.
I won't spoil it for you guys.
I want to play Gambit!
Torch?
Okay.
Sorry, you're at the wrong season right now.
Like...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
This guy was in a...
Yeah, this guy was in a coma.
He was in a coma during Torch season and just woke up and
was like, Hey guys, oh my god, can't believe they don't...
They didn't ban Torch guys.
They're fucking stupid.
Oh my god.
Little does he know.
Okay, I'm banning there.
I don't fucking care what any of these guys do.
I'm adding Daredevil.
Gone.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Oh, I don't have cough drops right now.
See, guys, no noise complaints.
Guys, no noise complaints yet after that outburst I had in
the beginning of the stream.
No knock, knock, knock.
Oh, we found the same thing.
God damn it.
for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Okay, I guess I guess the game decided to terrorize me.
Oh, that's that's fine.
Oh, man.
Oh, that's oh.
No, that's oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
No, Fucking I guess I why do I get the karma?
I guess what the fuck Why do I get the karma?
I was a good person in rivals I never flame anyone in rivals
like like um to their face Like like to their face.
Okay, okay I was just expecting the card tricks from dr.
Strange See, I, like, okay, but also when I play Missy, he,
ha ha, too, KC, yeah, it's that way to go.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All right.
All right, I don't think, I don't know, I'm not very
confident, guys.
Like I said, I also have not been playing that much.
I did not play since the new season came out.
Oh, nice.
Yay!
Or not the new season.
I haven't played since the anniversary came out.
Because, I don't know.
I just wasn't playing.
I don't know.
I was so busy, to be fair.
I was very busy.
Oh, my God.
He was so low.
He's so low.
Oh, my God.
My team is so low, too.
I need to reload.
Who the fuck?
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Poor team.
Oh, he didn't want to 1v1 me.
Good.
Because I didn't want to 1v1 him, too.
I got, I was a little...
Oh, shit.
No!
I almost had all.
Oh, we both almost had all.
Oh, I couldn't survive long enough.
I don't know if he could survive too.
No!
Oh my god, are you serious?
I just literally just got there.
Oh, we don't have a TP.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
We didn't want a TP out of there.
It's okay.
Okay.
Are we stacking?
Yes, we are.
That's good.
All right.
We're just gonna have to do this.
I don't want to...
a double support up but like i mean technically it's not
double oh okay oh my god that was that was insane but we had
no follow-up other than my auntie oh that's awkward oh that
is very awkward look i did the best i could in that scenario
i look i hit my aunties i just know it's not me Goodbye.
Oh, my.
Oh, and he missed.
He missed the bucky up.
That's okay.
Oh, and then I hope that's...
It's not me.
I'm no, I'm not the problem at least.
I know.
You can't play me.
I am not the problem here.
There you go.
Thank God.
What the fuck?
Wait, I hear him.
Oh, my God.
I...
I hear him.
oh my god I fucking I knew it I fucking knew it oh my god
we're dead we're dead we're dead we're dead I fucking knew
it I was like who the fuck is like I was trying to find a
flanker I was trying to find the flanker like I don't
understand why no one else was like no one else was like oh
who's the one flanking us I'm the only one looking at the
flanker I don't know why Like, why am I responsible for
that?
Oh, and we...
Okay, and we don't...
Oh, okay, that's fine.
I accidentally...
Okay, I'm so sad.
I am so sad.
Okay, that's fine.
No, I...
No, I knew that this team...
Let's just say that I have one more kill than our DPS
player.
so which is the same much because it's two uh but the fact
that uh two is the most kills that our dps players got is
what oh my god both flankers are okay i didn't realize i
didn't realize hawkeye was also behind us okay no our team
does not our team is not very The team does not know where
flankers are.
I can't see.
Oh my god.
I should not be trying to control two flankers.
I...
Okay.
I don't know what to do to save you.
I...
Avoid both CPS.
Okay, it's not me.
It's...
Time to switch things up.
Yeah.
By the way, who paid?
At least it's not me.
not team to win this one yeah though i yeah i definitely
need to avoid both ways i don't know it's whoever was
playing whoever was playing the spider-man
cheesy thank you for the tier one sub thank you thank you
season they give it a twitch prime thank you thank you i'm
not part of the problem okay how is i supposed to know when
i all that I have not just the siloed, but the Hawkeye
ulting at our spot.
Yeah, no, I don't want to play this.
Yay, freedom.
Yay, I think I derink.
Oh, wait, when I have equal amount of kills of the DPS.
Oh, my God.
When I'm about to, okay, this is a little sad.
fucking Invis has more damage than it.
Oh, no, I derank.
It's okay.
Sometimes that happens in life.
Sometimes life be like that.
Just be like that.
All right.
Oh, bro, you should not have had your Discord out.
People who linked your Discord, bro, like, okay.
I'm just like, bro, If you have your disc green up, man.
Mondays, am I right, guys?
Mondays.
All right, let's go back.
All right, I'll take you to the subway.
I'll show you the way.
The moment I figure out where the subway is.
So where is the subway again?
Oh, that's cute.
There's like a little file work there.
Oh, they're on the other side.
I'm gonna report them.
I don't care.
Oh, it's a hot topic?
Wee.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm going to head over.
Wait, can I, like, go?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, so.
So the fun thing about it is that I think, like, I think I
have to be Jeff, right?
Okay, so.
Oh, my God.
Look at me.
Bro, look at me.
Look.
I'm here for business.
Look at me!
Oh, look at me!
I'm so cute!
I'm a businessman!
Oh, I have to.
Oh, god damn, it's gonna take fucking forever, though.
Hello.
I love respecting women.
Me, too.
Like, yes, excuse me, I'm not normal.
Says the Virgin Overlord.
i'm not normal i'm a freak okay so basically what people
have learned this is new meta new meta for new business
owners is that they turn in the jeff they go jeff they all
go on the other side turn turn a penny and now it's a cage
show like or like not just penny but like you know like you
know i could do venom venom uh mantis you know and then
start dancing in the cage ages so it's the new meta it's the
new meta all right back to the venom all right hello
everyone hello to my oh my god look at that jeff look at
that hello jeff would you like a show
That's right.
No, but no touchy.
You're out of boundaries.
You can't touch.
That's a key right.
Okay, it was on my for you page.
So the freak finds me.
I can't touch it here.
That's a key right.
I'll say hi to the Jeff.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how do I say that?
There you go.
Hello.
All right, don't worry.
That's the key.
Oh, wait, they're gone.
Wait, they're all gone now.
Where did they all go?
It's just me and...
Oh, there he is.
Is...
Yes, yes.
The freak finds me.
I told you guys.
I'm just sad.
I can't believe...
Okay, did you guys see the...
course about the invisible woman on the freak side okay
everyone should like i don't know why people are still like
judging rivals for being like super gooner because that is
what they've been since season zero so like i don't
understand why people are still judging them like you know
what you know what you're gonna get at this point the new
okay so basically the discourse about invisible women's new
skin is that if you check her name card out I don't even
know where she is oh I think she found a game so if you
check her name card out the player card apparently in the
files you don't see on like on like the actual like the
in-game one but apparently in the in the files her entire
yeah I don't You know, frog-alicious?
You ain't girl.
Why are you asking?
Who's frog-alicious?
Oh, because they're like, I'm not gay.
I just want to know for sure.
Like, what is, what is Sep gonna do?
Like, he wants to know because he's like, I'm not gay.
I just want to know before I do anything.
Like, oh yeah, so her hoo-ha is like, out.
like not not like out out but like it's it's like there's
like a bump yeah so people were like what I don't I don't
have the tweet because like it's gone from my for you page
it's gone so like I'm very sorry guys I cannot show you that
I know a lot of you guys were like oh prove it yeah because
obviously you just want evidence right guys you just want
see it so you can see the evidence right like it's just that
right guys uh source trust me bro all right rivals am i
gonna do like rival leaks twitter it's usually in the rival
leak twitter accounts what is it called oh my god they have
so many different rival leaks twitter accounts But, like, I
don't remember which one is the actual leak account.
Oh, there we go.
It's this one.
There.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Rocket, okay.
That's...
That's interesting.
This team does not look very inspiring right now.
Oh, okay.
No, we're all right.
Okay, okay, okay.
Things are never mind.
Things look a bit okay.
Things look better.
Oh, but never mind.
Now, never mind.
One thing.
I said, things are looking better.
Doesn't imply.
Doesn't mean that you should go think.
It doesn't mean that.
But, like, anyway, like I said, like, people were
criticizing rivals for Gooner content.
I'm like, bro, like, everyone knows.
You think the player?
don't know like how do you think they're able to fund
million dollar lands guys how do you how do you bro how do
you think you're able to pay so many people to play rivals
responses and stuff bro like you know where that money comes
from the gooner shit gooner sells you know what they say sex
sells like literally that is the example yeah it's a tried
and true tactic
Oh my god, a fucking curse.
Okay, I'm gonna...
You normally would not waste that on this, but I will make
the exception.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I had to...
I hate using Kitos for it, but my team really needs Kitos.
Oh my god, she's playing this invisible woman.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Jesus Christ, I've been having to use like...
I almost have a...
Please, please, I almost have a...
Just live, just live, just live, just live, just...
Oh my god, I can't do anything about it.
It's okay.
It's fine.
He lived.
That's... Oh my god, that's huge!
That is actually huge.
Oh my, I have to reload though.
It's okay.
My team... My team's okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
We got you!
I don't know where the fuck the Scyloc is.
I got you, guys.
Oh my god, where the fuck is Asala?
I know he's gonna touch.
Oh, he's not, he's a pussy.
That's right.
Oh my.
Okay, I had to use so many...
Oh my god, I hate that I'm heal-bottling right now.
But like, my team.
If I don't, they die.
Okay.
Hello.
Please.
Stay alive.
I asked for you.
Alright, there you go.
I repositioned myself.
Alright, it's fine.
Okay, he's gonna drop the shield.
Watch.
Okay, never mind.
I forgot.
Strange also has a shield.
Okay.
Oh, this is...
Fine?
Oh, it's not.
You know what?
Fuck it.
my god okay oh shit oh okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're okay we're okay we're so healthy
except for him except for him except jk jk i'm i'm so good
at this game i'm actually insane at this game okay except
for that's awkward for a strange
Okay, I should have saved him.
I should have saved him.
I would admit if he could have lived.
There we go.
Thank you for the rank, Kikyo.
Thank you, thank you.
I've had a great stream.
I'm, I'm, I'm, is that the real, oh my God, is that the,
the, the, the, the, what was it?
The toxic Sakura?
From like four plus seasons ago?
Oh, I'm, like, oh.
I hear him.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
I have ears.
Sorry, guys.
I can't look at Chad.
Gambit takes, like, so much of my brain, and I don't have
much of that.
So, like, I have to focus so much.
Because I don't have a lot of my brain to use that for it.
Okay, I can.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I mean, Silok's gonna ult soon.
Watch this.
Boom!
There we go!
Let's go!
Okay, I didn't expect that, but that's fine, too.
Okay, I didn't...
Okay, Silo's gonna overflug.
Oh, Silo's dead.
That's good.
There you go.
We're fine.
See, look at that!
Silo killed her all for four fights.
Let's go.
Yay!
We did it!
Silo killed her all.
how the why do i not get mvp i did some fucking sick ass
gambit gameplay there like come on i deserve mvp like did
you clean up three different odds oh my god oh my god it's
okay it's okay i need a reload but it's okay we can save him
we can still save him oh we can definitely save him not
these guys though though but i can save these two these guys
are a bit more important oh whoops hey the tanks are alive
though hey the tanks are alive oh whoa oh no the takes are
still alive thanks are you still alive one of the tank is
still alive oh the one i got you that's good see we got we
got one of them We need it.
Okay.
I hope...
But where?
Boom!
It didn't wipe.
Because...
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
The Groot...
Look.
The Groot wiped it.
So, like...
Look, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
How is I supposed to anticipate the Groot walling me off?
Oh, wait.
Wall...
Making a portal.
Ooh.
Oh, R.
Strange.
Okay.
I need you to make sure I can see...
you okay all right let's go rush rush into them who cares
that's right just go just go just go gas gas gas gas gas gas
it's fine there you go see look at that early fight we did
it easy there you go the current score is three see i told
you i kept everyone up Never back down.
Uh, Kami, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
That's how you play Gambit.
Look at that.
Only good players don't have a Defts.
Hey, pizza.
My team is freaking out right now.
Why?
Oh, wait, it is you.
I was like, is this Is the Sakura that rage baited pizza?
Like, haha.
Yeah.
Or sigh.
Okay, I think I didn't read that.
Okay, I still read it.
And they are both slurs.
Totally fuck.
off wow you know they're mexican first off that's looking
wild bro that's the hell holy shit
hey god we're not on that team right now
all right how do you keep getting these games bro it's just
it's a king welcome to welcome to uh mario arrivals it's
practically all my games now honestly oh that's where i see
you oh wait i hear something behind us i don't like it oh my
god oh shit okay i was trying to fly but it didn't work okay
we sort of yeah we sort of fucked up we We let the...
We let the Hella take over.
I should not have fucking...
I should not have fucking got off high ground.
I don't know.
I thought...
I thought I was...
I thought I was safe, you know?
That's unlucky.
You're never safe.
Okay, now I have one death, but also...
So, you know what?
I just felt like...
I felt really bad for the enemy team, so I let them kill me.
Guys.
Oh, my...
Okay, I want to make sure...
My invis doesn't die, though.
Okay, I gotta make sure my other tank doesn't die also.
Okay, I just want to make sure.
Oh my god.
Guys, please.
Oh, this is bad.
This is...
Oh, no.
I...
They walled me off.
It's okay.
See, look at that.
I didn't have to use cleanse.
Look at that.
Cleanse not needed.
Oh.
Okay, the thing is, um...
Oh, my tics died.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, whoa.
Okay, guys.
Okay, all right.
You know, I did not expect that.
I thought we could live.
Oh, she's dead.
I saw the wolf walk over.
I knew it was over for her.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
why i did not oh my god that guy is crazy for importantly oh
my god is he okay is he okay he's okay he's okay i'm i'm
trying so hard to oh my god he is no longer okay um i don't
know what's going on for my team right now um i think i
tried everything i could to keep everyone alive Oh, please,
everyone is walled up.
Oh, no.
This is not good.
This is not good, guys.
This is absolutely not good.
This is...
Also, like, why did our exchange portal?
Oh, and now we have a magic.
I don't know if that is what's gonna save us.
Like, I don't know why he portal that.
the guru eco one oh my god healed enough damage on him yeah
no this is a lot of yeah i don't know about the magic pick
too i don't know if i don't know about that oh i was so
hopeful all right i'm just using that to stabilize at this
point like i'm gonna use this to stabilize like i this is
not about this is this is a defensive There's absolutely a
defensive ult.
Oh my god, guys, he's back on silo.
Maybe?
Oh, okay, that's not good, but...
All right.
All right, guys.
Everything is okay.
I got a little too... I might have got a little too cocky,
but...
Everything might be okay.
I definitely might have got a little cocky there.
Okay, he has all...
That silox looking for that shit.
Oh my god.
He's gonna...
I'm gonna put that in just in case.
I can't peek.
Okay, there...
Okay.
Okay, I'll take this.
I take that.
We're even.
I'm gonna save this because I know he has griddles soon.
So I'm scared.
I am absolutely scared I have to save cleanse for Shreel
Oh my god guys He's just slowly pushing up And I don't like
that He's just I don't like that He's just allowed to slowly
push up You know Um
Okay Did we get it?
Oh There you go Oh my god this is fine This is fine This is
fine I couldn't cleanse it because I used everything, but
that's okay My god, there's nothing I could do Yeah, no he
got fucking obliterated.
It's okay guys.
It's okay.
We could stabilize.
Oh my god.
We actually stabilized We what the fuck?
I did not expect that I did not expect the stabilization Did
we pour it?
No, don't say that.
What the fuck?
How did you get damage there?
I just wanted the extra.
Oh my god.
Guys, there is a flanker right there.
I'm not gonna peek that.
Like, how is he allowed?
How is that hell out in them?
There we go.
Fuck this.
Yeah, yeah, like you should not be allowed to do that.
Like it's just that easy Not be allowed to do that.
He absolutely should not be allowed I was like get out of
here
There you go Yeah, no, I had to take care of that myself.
I was like bro this guy should not be allowed to do this
shit.
He's doing Okay, okay, bro Okay, there is no way that they
let me die like that.
There is no way.
Bro, okay, that is my team.
My team literally fucking just not do anything.
Bro,
I can't believe my team actually...
Like, my team just let him walk past everyone.
I should have just walked to my team and let everyone die if
he's going to do that.
Tanaya Iron Fist.
I think I gotta kill their front line really easy.
He's like, I'm just gonna...
And you should play Mag, because I'm pretty sure their
Helo's, like, soft toggled.
You should just play Double Tent.
Play Mag.
The Magneto character.
I'm not worried about the Helo, though.
I'm worried about their front line running our back line
down.
I mean, I'm getting...
Our front line doesn't matter what that guy's doing.
Our other support just ran away from our other support.
brother bro so like i'm fine all right yeah can you put
something else with something bro no more earthquake okay
our no more is fucking doing like i bro
i've seen that account some sort of level what the i've seen
i've seen that account for weeks in this rank though why i'm
giving her a different account soft toggle is that you can
adjust You can adjust cheats to make it look like you're not
hacking specifically.
That's what soft toggling is.
You can adjust cheats to like, like have misses and stuff.
Because like, people who pay for subscription for cheats can
hard, like can customize it.
Which is fucking crazy that that is a thing.
But...
Hello?
Okay, I guess not.
Okay.
Hey, if he comes after us, it's on you.
Oh my god.
Excuse me, bro.
I gotta hide you out, y'all.
I'll take this.
Get on fast or die.
You going.
Okay, I can't do shit.
Here we go.
Oh, hey, Invis.
Okay, cool.
Just stand in front of the portal.
Stand in front of the portal.
Push this.
Oh my god, they portaled against you.
you just keep jumping in and out okay um oh there's that
there is that okay that's oh that's awkward that's awkward
yo we don't know how you defend the target area my only one
here oh that's so awkward that is so awkward
It's okay, we have, oh, it's here.
It's okay, I can save him.
But who will save me?
Alright, we have everyone.
Alright, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Let's go with this.
We have to go with this.
I'm not even gonna fucking push up right now.
Because I know, yeah, I...
Oh, shit.
What's going on?
Okay.
I don't know what's going on, but I think things are okay.
I think, yes, yes, okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Things are okay.
I'm just like, I think it's okay.
Okay, things are okay.
I don't know.
I don't know if we're going to win this, but I think things
are okay.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Make way for the king of teams.
that's fine that's everything will be okay do we I don't
think I think I think hella's good into their comp bro
you're saying like full dove that's why we like lost the
first plant bro why is this guy blaming earthquake who is
doing everything like no not you bro bro like earthquake is
actually like card carrying in everything double tank first
point right okay this is weird
I don't fuck with that right now like I couldn't even play
the game I ain't gonna I mean don't fuck with that I don't
fuck with that look the good content is the characters like
I'm off limits here
like in this game
I think Bucky would be really good.
Lois is our promote Peter thing, guys.
God forbid, a man be a little curious.
Let's put like a bunch of pressure on their tanks.
I'll literally just destroy them.
Oh my god, I want to anti him so bad.
I'm going to wait until...
Keep walking.
Oh my god.
Oh
There you go I didn't have purple back in right now What do
you mean they're like purple purple purple Go bro Bro, it's
very hard to purple here Oh my god, oh my god, okay, okay, I
had to use this guy Oh, this is bad.
I didn't have cleanse.
I didn't have cleanse I didn't have cleanse Oh Oh, they went
triple support Actually, we don't need to give you we can
make it.
We can walk walk walk walk walk You guys gotta walk harder
when I go in because they just all look at me So it makes it
easy.
Yeah, bro.
I mean, they're all triple support.
I don't think they're gonna kill I don't think I think I
think the iron fist I Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Okay, look guys a lot of anti like there is no way you can
oh no Is my team okay?
I don't know you got to get trained up.
Oh, you know, you're going to be early Bro, okay
You should have saved this for the Mantis call.
The Mantis call.
Mag, bro.
You're the one that told him the strange job.
He's getting different comms right now.
He's getting conflicting comms.
It's not his fault.
Make sure y'all stay by each other.
He'll heal each other, bro.
They swapped the sides.
Bro, it's not his fault.
You were giving so many conflicting comms.
Oh my god, they're gonna have, I'm gonna use this real
quick.
You were like, bro, you gotta up, bro, you gotta up.
And he's like, bro, don't up, don't up, bro.
And then he up, okay.
I'm trying to make sure.
Oh, wait, they see nine.
Yay.
All right, nice.
We did it.
It's just that, guys, it was just that easy.
Oh, my God.
This game is so easy, guys.
Oh my Such an easy game No pressure or anything Yeah Oh and
I can just get plus 16 Okay that's cool That's like Yeah
Everything was just gonna be okay Everything I don't even
know okay who is the The shittiest player Who is the Oh my
My god, okay, we avoid this guy.
He doesn't know what to do.
This guy, this guy was the one that's playing Mystery
Heroes.
He did not know what the fuck to play.
Yeah, that was some Mystery Hero shit.
Yeah, bro, played the entire roster there.
Bro was so fucking confused.
Not quite.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
There, thank you for the tier one sub.
yeah he was spinning every time he died he's spinning a
wheel and be like what do i play next
he's just he was just curious
bro is the marvel rival oh wow you so what the fuck what do
you mean by that you solo kill i do i do either it's mostly
on stream i mostly solo kill but off stream i with friends
because like you know um if i suffer i like okay this is my
logic also if anyone asked me one to play sometimes i like
mostly always say yes um um and because like i'm not
grinding for a rank or anything anymore i'm not grinding for
a rank or anything anymore so it doesn't really matter if i
lose yellow or not um unless i lose a lot of either then it
matters um for offstream the thing is I usually I don't solo
queue off stream mostly mostly because it's like uh because
like for stream I solo queue I have no mind solo queuing
because like you know you guys are suffering with me but off
stream I'm like I need someone to stuff you know you're like
I don't want to suffer alone so I'm like I have to have
someone to like fucking suffer with me I need to bring
someone down with me to this hellhole but like when I'm
streaming I'm like at least you guys are to madness um yeah
yeah you get to watch the suffering misery loves company
exactly it's rake we have to suffer i i'm you know what i
missed i think like i think times square isn't the same
times square oh shit hello times times square role playing
just isn't the same
Yeah, that's right.
That's right, Jeff.
You like that, don't you?
Yeah, he's...
Oh my god, I forgot about the sneakers.
He's on an important business meeting.
That's looking right.
What does it say?
Hey, guys.
What the fuck?
Are y'all fighting over a girl?
Real, thank you.
We don't want Katie.
anyways we can what the oh my god it's sep it's him again
it's fucking sep oh my god he's never left he's still here
bro sep's the guy who was like are you a woman because he
was like bro i'm not gay so i need to know if you're a woman
or not to like all the to like some like the women repeat
offenders hey Seth
come here
that's right you know you want to and I'll be like I'm a mad
no where is he taking me oh over here I was gonna be like i
wonder how he'll react and be like yeah slap that slap that
ass and then i'll be like i'm a man and then so see how he
reacts oh don't worry i'm here to give him a show too
oh wait oh oh okay i thought he left oh can i get out there
if Wait, does it work on Loki?
Wait a minute.
Can I be Loki and clone myself in here?
Wait, is that possible?
Oh, it's not.
Oh my god, he fucking baited me.
You can only do this on Jeff.
I'm so sad.
You can only...
Oh, well.
Gotta take the...
Excuse me, sir.
I need to take the subway.
With my very important business meaning.
Oh, I can use...
Punisher?
Wait, how do I do this?
I don't know how.
seen the jeff way all right we're just punished you can tell
i don't know where how do i do it like here i can't turn it
here no turrets allowed did they patch it guys so you won't
i don't know why the subway won't allow my turret
what the fuck nice wait wait i can figure this out what the
okay i can figure this out Turn around and smoke.
No, that's a lie.
My subway card.
Oh, you spam it until it works.
Okay, that's okay.
What the fuck is going on in my chat?
Because Sep is trying to find me.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Why is trust me GM?
Oh, I'm...
What GM do you think you want to be here?
oh my god he's fucking doing placements on his 20th account
right now god damn it doing fucking placements on his like
20th account oh trust me is uh he was he won the guanjo land
not the million dollar the one um he's he's a really good
tank player that should not be in gm1 is 25 for this.
Because majority of players here are GM players.
So that's the one that sucks the most.
I don't know.
It's fine if it's like a majority Celestial Lobby.
But half the people here are GM.
We.
Easy.
I assume he's just doing placements on his 20th account.
Oh, and they back.
Damn it, the fuck am I gonna play now?
We have three support plate.
Alright.
Guess I'm Mantis.
I mean, I'll play Mantis with triple support.
Banning Moon Knight.
Who the fuck banned Moon Knight?
Banning Moon Knight is so true, but I forgive you because
you're GM1.
Why did we not ban Hella?
Oh, I just noticed.
I laughed, but I'm also crying.
Because I realized what we banned over Hella.
What we banned over Hella.
I was like, wait, you're right.
Why didn't we ban Hella?
Yeah.
Maybe it was for me, blushes.
Hellenic Moore is gonna make me very upset, but it's okay.
Yeah, I stream on Twitch too.
I mean, I do like guerrilla streams here.
I don't know if he's gonna make it before.
You know, I trust the Venom to make it in time.
Never mind.
Here's another damage boost just in case.
And also you.
Come on, Venom!
Come on!
Come on, Venom.
I was expecting you to dive in already.
I gave... Okay, there we go.
There we go.
There's the damage boost that I was waiting for.
Oh, no.
Hey, guys.
Hey, there's a... Wow.
Oh, we lost... We lost Wolf.
Oh, my... Oh, hey!
Guess what?
They ran a real DPS cop.
That's cool.
How did they...
How did they have a Hell in the More player?
Like, oh my god, this is rigged.
This is actually rigged.
This is scripted.
There is no way.
Like, how did they coincidentally have Hell in the More
players when we don't even have Hell in the More players?
It's definitely scripted as hell.
Like, There's no way.
Our fucking DPS player is a Punisher.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Come on.
I ulted.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Oh, nice.
They double support ulted.
That's cool.
I wish I...
Oh, that's not cool.
That's not...
Okay.
Alright.
That's a...
Oh wait, they don't have any support.
Not even minus 20, it's minus 26.
I don't understand.
This is fully scripted.
I refuse to believe.
They're paid actors.
These are fucking paid actors.
There's no way.
Oh my god, go, go, go.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, come
on, I even fucking, okay, that's fine, that's fine, that's
fine, that's fine, back up, back up, breaks, breaks, breaks,
breaks, breaks, breaks, breaks, breaks, breaks, breaks,
breaks, breaks, breaks, all right, no, this is, no, I don't
think it's possible, guys, I, I, oh, I'm sorry, Mac, there
was nothing I could do, I'm sorry, Mac, It's cooked.
He definitely didn't.
He actually had...
It's actually like paid actors.
I refuse to believe that like...
Not only did they get Trust Me, but also they got a name
more in Hella Player.
And what the fuck did we get?
What did we get?
We didn't get out of those.
Technically, I could play Cloak for this.
They didn't have a mag, right?
Yeah, they didn't have a mag, so it's cloak time.
It's not winnable, but I like to pretend to...
I like to pretend it is.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Like, oh, this is not.
Never mind.
I just saw our kills.
I mean, where is the kills?
Sorry, I saw the lack of kills.
what kills it's okay guys I mean I'm gonna get minus what 26
but like it's okay guys looks it's everything will be fine
oh my yeah I I knew we were gonna hit that hopefully we can
go back here and won the fight oh yeah that was supported
all right hello oh yeah watch this okay he just walked away
it's okay guys i need to know who bad moon night and i'm
gonna avoid them i need to know who it was oh
why can't the hell of a more player be on my team i don't
need yeah no no i agree all right i'm gonna use the bathroom
i'm dodging this queue
I'm dodging this queue.
No, this queue.
This queue is...
I'm dodging it.
I feel like I'm just going to get paid actors.
Alright, I'll be right back.
Don't worry, guys.
While I dodge this queue.
I'll be right back.
I need to use the bathroom.
Or I'm back.
I have to blow my nose, too.
I am not...
I'm not coming back to that queue.
so we are we are absolutely not coming back to these these
cues i who's this guy okay wait coney's playing all right
this is the one way i know all right as long as when these
people find their game i'm going back in i'm i i'm not good
i i'm not good i i'm not re-rolling this knowing that trust
me is on a gm1 account i'm not i'm not re-rolling i don't
trust my luck anymore i as soon as they open this net yeah
it's okay i know i'm at the way for a very a while but it's
okay i can wait getting the best i just guys i just don't
trust i don't trust my luck anymore for this year.
Oh, guys, okay, you guys know how I told you guys about the,
um, I I used to be, like, not superstitious.
but, um, they, they're, you know, that Japanese calendar,
uh, joined, no.
No.
I am absolutely not joining the queue.
Like, this is, wait, oh yeah, I was gonna say it.
Um, I was born into, I need to know, who fucking bad moon
night who the fuck was it all right oh my god this guy the
the fucking punisher player the wolverine punisher player
bad moon night okay okay you don't play hella why did you
bad moon night if you don't play hella you bad who are you
who oh yeah okay you see i hide my profile oh oh my god he
was the gm2 though no okay all right he was a gm2 player as
well yeah no get off of my list as well yeah
oh my god what was i gonna say before i got it before i i I
realized how fucked that game was.
That was literally, like, scheduled.
It was literally paid after.
Oh, yeah.
Japanese luck calendar.
So there's, like, so the thing, um, so on the Japanese luck
calendar.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
Let me, sorry.
I know you need your jingle jangle whenever I tell a story.
So your eyes are on the screen.
Um, um, there is a Japanese luck calendar where it ranks
your birthday.
uh based off of like how lucky you are for the year so for
my birthday for 2025 um it was really bad it was like like
the last two pages bad but like for the beginning of this
year and I was like no way there's no way it's that bad and
a lot of really bad things happen to me this year
So, and that's what, that's what I started, I started, like,
believing in it, because I was just like, there's no way, I
can't be even more unlucky, but good thing for next year,
next year, I'm on the first page, that's right, I think I
was like, I think it was like 14th or some shit, so like,
I'm like, oh, thank God, oh, thank God, I'm on the first
page.
the first page now i'm like on the 14th it can't get worse
now no it was really bad it was it was oh my god they still
don't have a game they're all waiting for me they're like
come on toky you all come on we're all waiting on you come
on toky
we we need we need another we need a game guys We need a
game, so you should queue up.
All right, okay, that's good.
All right.
We won't jump you, he promised.
I was like, no, no, no.
You can't fool me this time.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Now we can go back.
I miss.
You know what?
Maybe there's still role players in Doom match.
You know?
they're still out there maybe maybe there's people who still
they're like can't go to town square you punk if you want to
role-play hey guys are they're still are we still
role-playing here hey any non-time square buddies come on
that's right I swear to God about you dude I'm so confused
on which invid is Why did you walk away, bro?
That's right.
Come on.
Wait, where did Invisgo?
Hey there, Jeff.
Do you want to have fun?
Yeah!
Look, he sat on a...
Oh, guys.
He had a long day at work, okay?
Business Jeff had a long day.
Oh, shit!
Hey, hey, hey.
He paid for this.
had a very stressful day dude on his nine to five you don't
understand okay who who's where's that bitch where are you
where are you we're trying to have a moment here don't worry
the view is better here business chef the view is a lot
better bro capitalism is so stressful oh shit okay Equality,
equality for all
Look, Derek, oh, he's gone He's like, finally I can relax
And then he got, he got snapped away They knew the
assignment He was like, finally some real entertainment And
then he got dragged away went to his room unlucky he can't
see um he has his other senses he could hear and like feel
the movement you know you know when you're when venom's ass
is twerking it and then he can feel the the wind from the
movement yeah he can feel the wind and the vibrations he can
hear the claps God just cuz he's blind doesn't mean he can't
enjoy a good time oh shit this is a fucking magic one me one
oh wait he's back where did he go hey guys hey don't
worry wait how did he came back he was like it's like I
can't I couldn't leave guys I had to come back
Aura.
See, I told you there's still role players here.
Yeah, so you can hear, you can feel the, the heat, like, you
can feel the shape of it, too.
Like, he knows that's a good ass.
Yeah, he came back for a second.
I look at everyone's fighting.
Oh, hey.
Hey, luxury loader.
That's right.
You're, that's right.
go yeah boy bro billionaires gotta find a way to relax too
look at that we have two shows a 1v1 of magic and this
all right what is this please don't ban hawkeye
what a okay oh and uh and he's on my tea
okay yeah yeah yeah i get i i i of course of course he's on
my team penny okay where am i where am i
all right well i hope one of these players are hella players
leave hella open please okay okay that's cool okay thank god
the hawkeye player plays hella
all right my bad daredevil i don't care i don't trust the
other team to ban daredevil i swear to god if we let
daredevil through i swear to fucking god i i don't care i i
don't care if we both ban daredevil like i'm not taking my
chances we are not letting a nuclear bomb into this game
i swear to god oh thank god oh thank fucking god because i'm
not letting the goddamn nuke into our fucking lobby all
right here we go all right i'm very concerned on whether or
not we have a tank player because it doesn't seem like it oh
no oh no i don't know if we have a player that can play tank
all right we want to play number eight oh no our dps i mean
like phoenix is fine but our other three our other two is
hawkeye and i oh okay you know what this is not too bad this
is not too
Oh, oh, and he plays...
Okay, no, okay, we're looking better.
This cop is looking a little...
Like, a lot better now.
This is...
Oh, and then...
He's five.
Oh, I didn't...
I missed my...
I missed the...
The pull.
That would have been sick if I got it.
But I didn't...
I didn't get it, though.
okay there's five oh my god i have not i haven't played
fucking invisible woman in so long i've been just spamming
gambit i'm not used to this at all i've just been spamming
gambit the entire oh my god okay it's bad
it's okay it's okay it's fine oh wait they have widow I mean
hey look at that nice disappear alright don't worry I have
my up are they running triple they are not we have we
technically we should have in all okay that's okay that's
okay That's not okay.
It's not okay anymore.
It's not okay.
This is like the only thing I could do.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no, no, no.
Oh Yeah, no, I know in this in this gambit is like meta, but
it's like Yeah I don't think our other DPS is.
It's okay.
They don't have...
It's okay, guys.
Okay, no, they do have those.
I just realized the Mantis still has those.
Guys, we just got a...
Oh, fucking alright.
Goodbye.
That's okay.
I have my own shield.
I don't need kills.
I have this.
It's okay.
I'll just stay here.
Um...
Oh, this is bad because I just, oh, I just, oh, it's okay.
You have this now.
Oh, it's okay.
Where is she shooting it?
Oh, what?
What happened?
What do you want from us?
Oh, my God.
i just think like dps wise was just not it it's
no i think i think maybe we might not have good dps there's
maybe um wait what are we we're back at being how oh because
of iron fist okay all right i don't know bar of this that's
okay we're gonna use rocket all right nice that should be
fine it's not fine oh wait it's it's that should be fine
that should be fine normally okay oh okay that's fine i i
got really worried because um because i thought that emma
had a lot more hp but it's okay we got the and then the
windows right here yeah please kill her okay nice all right
it's okay I can heal myself I don't try I'm strong
independent woman I can just heal myself I don't need heals
it's all right it's okay guys it's it's it's doable I don't
have a lot of...
Oh my god, May.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh my god, oh my shield was destroyed so fast.
But see, look at that, guys.
Guys, please.
I'm not a miracle worker.
All I can do is put a band-aid on things.
Like, I'm not a miracle worker, guys.
Please.
Oh my god, please, I don't have...
Oh, we gotta keep Mag up.
We gotta...
Oh my god, we gotta get him to have to reset.
Oh, he doesn't have to reset.
Thank God.
Okay, okay, we're good.
We're good.
Oh, he fucking came back.
Okay.
That's good.
That is so good for me.
Okay, why?
Okay, okay, that's...
Okay, I was gonna say my rocket is...
so special my oh my god i was good i i'm thank god we we
fucking i'm so happy okay thank god at least our we shot the
phoenix up but i wish we got the phoenix up please guys
please please i there's not only so much i could do There
you go.
Oh, I'm trying.
Get away from me.
Oh, God.
I cannot get hit.
There you go.
All right.
It's okay.
I almost have a...
Okay.
It's okay.
Push up, push up, push up, push up with that.
Push up.
You guys.
Push up, push up, push up.
using this aggressively okay that's fine we i guess we don't
use it aggressively okay
i'll go i okay i'm just a little sad that my team like saw
the uh and just actually what the fuck are the indigo i'm
just i'm just wondering why we all just paused wait they
haven't popped anything we were all just standing there i
wanted to use it aggressively there we go okay but they have
multiple alts that are gonna like keep killing us that we
need to react like defensively to and even then using
aggressively we actually have to be able to walk as a team
you are popping it so far up that we are losing four seconds
before anybody and it's only me who's even standing in it we
they're all four of us okay i'm not gonna argue i'm not
gonna argue all four of us were fucking in front of the y
'all and we didn't move up i'm not even gonna argue with him
like this guy like we all literally just stared at it we
stared at the y'all i was just trying to pull a cyphe
because he uses his invisible aggressively i'm not i'm he's
been hard stuck in this Halo in a long time.
I'm not going to argue with him.
He plays this game so much.
He is actually, I'm not going to get rage baited.
Yeah, I can't reason with a movable object.
Like, did we not see a rocket fucking all of Phoenix up two
times?
But, oh, yeah.
Like, we were so lucky.
We all fucking shot the Phoenix up.
Much better.
They were so scared to walk forward.
That's the thing.
Everyone was so scared to walk forward.
Like, all...
Like, I saw we were all in front of the Ups.
But then nobody moved forward.
Like...
Hey, I'm not gonna...
I saw what I saw.
All right, nice side ahead.
What the fuck?
Who's feeding this up?
Oh, yeah?
Oh, look at that.
Look at this Invis.
Use it aggressively instead of defensively.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, how come they were able to walk forward?
That's the thing, I see a lot of like high rank invisible,
like the pro invisible players.
What they do is literally they use your invisible
aggressively.
Alright, I'll use it.
Oh, there you go.
I have to use the, oh look at that, I'm walking forward.
Oh, you live, yep, look you live.
Whoa, guess who saved the rocket guys?
Whoa, oh, I'm dead.
It's fine.
Just press W.
I don't even know where people... Oh, he's so dead.
He's yeah, we're not... he's not saveable.
No, I just think...
Oh.
Oh, nice.
See, look at that.
I saved him.
You're welcome.
Oh, guess who just saved his fucking life?
Wow!
Yeah, but I'm the one reason why we lost that game.
Oh, hey guys.
Okay, I tried my best to save this guy.
I had all...
I had every fucking... I shielded him and everything.
Oh, and then...
Oh, I lost the slack game.
Oh, see, this is what I hate.
You make, and quote unquote, one mistake, and then, like,
everyone's fucking dog pales you, and then I'm just like,
okay, why wouldn't we push in at any of our other fights?
How did we lose all our other fights?
Yeah.
Like, oh, I fucking blocked the spotter, man.
Yeah, 4-7 DPS is the problem.
But Doki is the problem.
Oh, yeah, I got it with a DPS.
You're right.
No, I honestly, I think, I do think that Rivals is getting
more and more toxic in terms of, like, playing rank.
I saw a lot of people saying that they stopped playing rank.
Like, people are being toxic and quick play in general, too.
And I can see that.
I will say the toxicity in Rivals is, like, almost at the
same level as Valorant now.
Which sucks, because I do like, I love this game.
But, like, the players in this game, some of the players in
this game, the fucking ego, and, like, they don't see people
as people.
Like, that's what I hate the most.
people anymore.
No, it has got really bad.
Like, that's why it's like, usually I'd, like, go on a whole
spiel about that fucking guy that was trying to blame on me,
but I was just like, I'm not gonna argue with you.
Like, bro, fuck it off.
Like,
I know you've been hard stuck around this Elo for a while
now.
Like, I've seen you around since when I, like, fuck around.
For so long.
Alright, that's okay.
There's one thing that will always cheer me up.
This time.
Yeah, there's quick play players that are now behaving like
rank and stuff.
That's why I'm trying to be more... I'm trying to be more
chill.
I'm trying!
I'm trying to be more chill.
I'm like, I'm not gonna argue with you.
I...
I'm impervious to damage.
I'm trying here Now I'm gonna dance my anger out Now we're
here to jingle jangle That's right Hello Can anyone pay
attention to me This is a cry for attention
This is a cry for attention right now I had a bad rank game
I mean i need i need people to pay attention to me
i gotta shake out my anger i want to feel appreciated as a
support
yeah i desire human validation right now
it's actually crazy that like they they the support when
like what did the dps do not for the last how many fights
like you know we had three dps what the fuck did the dps do
oh but i ulced that badly so the entire reason why we lost
was because of that all right
That's crazy.
He could have opened his mouth for any other moment to shit
to talk the DPS, but he chose to open his mouth to me
That's that's the crazy part he didn't have the balls to
fucking say anything else But then he had the balls to say
shit to the support
He thought he could oh my god, they're all console players.
What the fuck like Holy shit!
It's just console.
Look at all these console players.
This is why we had a support strike.
Don't make us bring it back.
It was...
I know for the people who...
I like accidentally was in the support strike only because I
wasn't playing rivals at that time because I was so busy.
So I didn't have to deal with the support strike.
Also because it was dive.
Dive fucking sucks.
I hate playing.
Which hero do you think you want to be...
Dive fucking sucked at that time.
It was like hard dive too.
So I'm fucking with that.
How many fantastic...
I swear to God.
This time is like fantastic hours.
How am I gonna vanish from this match?
Okay, there is a player here.
That like...
Was a shitty person to me.
I'm gonna see if they'll I'm gonna see if they'll start
fucking be shitty being shitty again before I say anything
wasn't Necro's the reason for support strike it was also
because it was dive so like some people didn't even know
what Necro said they were just like dive sucked so like we
we all just stopped playing because dive was just not fun to
play like play against so a lot of support players was
because it was not fun at all
I won't say it until they be a shitty person because actions
have consequences because it's like you want to be a shitty
person well you got to deal with the consequences of being a
fucking shitty person like
yeah you like do you like like bullying people in this game
like oh then let's then be do it publicly Yeah, do it
publicly then
I'm very petty That's why I was like If I'm gonna get flamed
I'm doing I might as well stream I might as well stream if
I'm getting flamed You know Because at least At least I can
make content out of it
At least I'll get like You know of income from being yelled
at.
Never get flamed for free, guys.
Never get flamed for free.
Yeah.
Words to live by.
I know.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, they have a Jeff.
Oh my, I would play Jeff if I know how to play Jeff.
And I'm like too scared to play Jeff because I know
absolutely I will 100% actually get flamed for it.
Like if I wasn't going to get flamed for it, I will for
Jeff.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Jesus Okay, you're taking way too much damage, bro Oh my god
Oh my god Okay, guys, guys, we're all taking so much damage
The thing is, I should play Jeff Only because Jeff is so
good If they have a Jeff, you have to play a Jeff But like,
I don't know how to Oh, that's Jeff and I know him I don't
know how to Oh, and that's what I'm afraid of I am stronger
than ever.
Some assistance, please.
Well, well.
Cosmic.
My interns.
Bye.
I need assistance.
Oh my.
Invisible?
All right.
Oh, what the fuck?
I mean, okay, I'll take this.
Okay.
Nice.
I want nothing.
Hey, I want it.
I want it.
I'm not fucking shooting it.
I'm shooting it, guys.
What the fuck?
Where are we shooting at?
There we go.
Who is he shooting at?
Okay.
I don't know.
There's so many things going on.
Oh, that widow now?
Is that widow?
No.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, I got scared for him.
Okay, I'm gonna go here.
I'm scared here.
Yep, that's why I was scared.
That's why.
That was why I was scared.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, no.
He's dead.
He is dead.
Does he still have...
Does he still have his ult?
Oh, he ults it too early.
Why did you ult so early?
Oh, no.
I thought I thought the old was still there.
I don't know the counting for it I wish I knew the counting
for the old stuff I'm so bad at counting for the thing It's
okay Oh my god, it's not okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
I wanted to go in and stall a little longer
It's okay.
We have oh goodbye.
Goodbye Adam.
Oh, unless
All right.
Everything is fine.
I don't know anymore.
No, that's not fine.
We don't have else for it.
We don't have else for that.
That's why it might not be fine.
Oh, yeah, I was going to say we don't have else for that.
It's okay.
Do you only add Pufasa 9 L has left the voice chat?
Okay, you can do that.
Okay.
That's... Why did he leave the voice chat?
Incredible.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I love Rivals.
I love Marvel Rivals.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I mean, come on, let's go.
Let's go.
What the fuck?
Come on.
You should be able to do stuff with that, right?
Nice.
Jesus.
Okay, guys, guys.
I think we won the fight, guys.
Guys, guys.
No, guys.
I think, guys, I really think we might have won the fight,
guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's, whoa.
Um, that's okay.
Um, I don't know.
I had a feeling that the fight was 100 already, That's okay
guys.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I think it was fine.
Okay, I'm going in here.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I...
It's fine, I think.
Okay.
Are we...
Is this winnable?
You know what, fuck it.
Let's fucking do this.
Okay.
Guys, guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
They all did for it.
You know what?
That's fine.
We got the Groot alt out.
It wasn't a winnable fight, but we got the Groot alt out.
Like, that's a trade I'm willing to make.
It's fine.
We got the Groot alt out.
Guys, that's okay.
That's okay.
I'm okay with that.
What the fuck?
How?
Oh my god.
I was like, where am I getting hit from?
I gotta slowly back up.
Sorry, guys.
I think I can maybe grab my load in time.
Bro, okay, there's this fucking arm fist that's just
punching our exchange.
Can we, like, do something about that?
Man, I wish we had Jeff players.
That would be pretty cool about now.
Okay, nice.
I mean, it would be fucking cool if we...
Oh, no.
I don't know about this.
Okay, nice.
That's fine.
He just...
That's okay.
That's good.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Okay, I don't want to use this yet.
But so I'm hoping that...
Okay, nice.
I don't have to use a...
Nice, see?
I...
Self-restraint!
Self- oh my god, guys, guys.
He's one.
Self-restraint, I did it all.
Okay, I'm a bit afraid of.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Please tell us we live this.
Dang it, that's good.
That is good.
That is, I had to use this because I don't know.
I actually fell down.
Oh my god, please.
Please tell me we're...
Oh no, oh no, we were all stuck in there.
Alright, it's okay.
Surely we have a strange that can pour it up.
This is fine.
fine we have a strange portal and then i go this and then i
i try and body block i i try my what the fuck where's our
portal where's our where's our portal where did our portal
go okay that's fine that's fine oh they didn't touch point
that was not fine You know, the thing is, even if they
counter-portaled, the portal should still show up.
So I'm like, what happened?
The portal should still show up.
That's the thing.
I don't understand why the portal didn't show up.
Like, did he, like, stop the portal accidentally?
Yeah, no, I look behind.
There was no second portal.
He got tired.
Like, I was so confused.
Because, like, even if you get counter portal, another
portal should...
He should still...
No, he didn't get stunned.
He didn't get stunned.
That's the thing.
He canceled it.
I was like, where did our portal go?
How did it get canceled?
Does it not work?
Does it...
No, I don't know what happened.
I was so confused.
Even if a strange counter portals you, a second port- He
should still be able to put up the portal.
You just have to- You should be able to see the other
portal.
I mean, I could watch the POV, yeah.
Wouldn't hurt.
His arms got tied.
I was so confused.
Alright, let's see.
He stopped the portal!
Oh, my- No, wait, did he actually get hit by Phoenix?
Where was the Phoenix?
Wait, what?
How did he get hit by the Phoenix?
Ha!
Okay, wait, I gotta see.
How did he get hit by the Phoenix?
Where's our Phoenix?
Oh, it's here.
How did he get hit?
Oh, my...
Oh.
You can see it.
through the see it goes through the portal look look that
should have went through the portal so i couldn't see i
couldn't stand in front of it because there was the counter
portal he she did not plan this i wanted to i was trying to
stand in front of him and then the enemy portal showed up So
I couldn't stand in front of him anymore.
And then it hit him.
Oh my god.
That's actually so bullshit.
No, it's...
The portal came in at such a...
The portal came in at such a good timing.
Like, I don't think...
There's no way they planned this in fucking Celestial 3.
There's no fucking way.
Celestial 1 is top 500.
But I refuse to believe that...
these two players um groupkin tick tock and ago planned the
fucking portal to bot to block her pov so i refuse to
believe these two players work together to fucking plan this
i that's crazy because the portal blocked the I didn't see
the feed like I couldn't body block it That's actually crazy
The agents working overtime today for me
Agents going crazy right now.
Oh nice.
I got a game
Elo crimes at this hour actual Elo crimes Which hero do you
think you want to be today i think i'm just today i'm at the
i'm i'm loser queuing today i'm getting it's actually crazy
i don't know how where all these mr fantastic one tricks are
one trickers are coming from but today i think i've got like
at least five plus that mr fantastic one tricks i don't know
where they're all coming from and then he bands adam
Mr. Fantastic One Tricks, too.
They're all different Mr. Fantastic One Tricks.
I don't know where they're coming from.
I have not seen this many in so long.
It's fine.
I don't care.
I'm not letting him fucking ban Adam.
It's fine.
As long as he's not fucking banning Adam.
You are...
Okay, we're all...
Let's roll it.
Let's fucking roll it.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
Who knows what we're gonna ban today?
no it's not mr.
fantastic has never been meta
they have an adam hard one otp oh i don't know maybe you
should have fucking said that before just banning adam oh
wow why didn't you say it why don't you say oh they have an
atom one trick whoa you had two bands to say that
pro is not a tele you had to know telepathically like we
just think you're fucking terrible at banning because a lot
of people are
he announces the problem within two business days He had so
he's like burn at him.
I'm like bro.
I've seen so many dumb ass bands today Like unless you tell
me he is a one trick.
I will not listen to you
Yeah, I know he has 600 hours and he's still GM bro like
What are you afraid of mr.
fantastic who is also hearts like GM Oh my
god, and they have a penny player too that's That's great.
That's actually great.
They also have a penny flanker as well.
There you go.
Oh my god.
I have to like...
I have...
Oh my god.
I have to be very aware, by the way.
Okay.
I...
Please.
Please!
I peeled for my cloak!
three times and our cloak did not peel for me once i'm sorry
i hate i hate support players i don't feel i oh my god i'm
sorry that like is my biggest pet peeve i don't get that
tilted unless like i see my support after i saved your life
20 times it's just something about it you know like you know
you get that right It's just something about it.
I still got it, bitch.
I still got the fucking...
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh, yes.
Let's ban that.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we had to just die on point.
Wait.
You wouldn't get it, Doki.
Oh, wow.
I wish we banned Hella.
I wish we banned Hella, guys.
Man, if only...
Oh, my God.
I fucking...
I didn't...
What?
I'm sure the TP'd done already.
What happened?
Also, that Adam was not the problem.
problem at all.
It's literally...
That atom was not an issue at all, I will have to say.
Like, I literally shut down the atom so fast.
Trying to shut down near Spider-Man, too.
I wish it.
Okay, we gotta push up though.
Guys, guys, we can all be...
Okay.
I have to make sure.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Can we touch point?
That'll be pretty cool.
Nice.
I'm proud of you all.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
At least we live.
Some of us live.
This is a lot of orcs that we do not have to use.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god, I'm trying.
I really am.
Oh my god, they're talking about this guy.
See, this guy was not an Atom OTP.
By the way.
I remember this guy was not an Atom OTP.
Oh, that is awkward.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
Okay, I talk shit.
I get it.
That's just karma.
I think there was just...
There's just too many alts to fucking counter with support
alts.
But we don't use our...
We don't use our cloak defensively.
Which is...
Fucked up because I have to use Gambit ult defensively.
Which is something I don't want to do.
there you go i saved this from that well i almost saved us
from that
look i am trying so hard to heal us but our cloak died so
fast
like but our oh my god i wanted to badhellen too but i i
can't believe it i was gonna badhellen We could have got the
Hella fan, guys.
But we don't have a player that plays Hella?
Oh my god, I swear to god, this is like...
It's actually crazy.
How do we have all the players?
Like, how do we have all the unique one-tricks on our team?
Like...
It's actually, like...
Impressive, you know, it's very impressive to get all like
the unique one tricks here
Here we go, I have to use that
Bro, not only do I have the fantastic player like Bro, look
at my tank front line Like I don't have an M up there Like,
like, what is my, oh my god, okay, that's fine.
It's not, but, like, I'm just coping it now.
Oh,
man, I wish I had.
an ult for that you know i wish i had an ult for the hella
that would be pretty neat not gonna lie
that i'm sorry that was my bad look i i was just i could
have healed you there i would admit i could have healed her
for that one i no i've accepted today was not a climbing day
but I it was never like like I had a feeling you know like
today was not that day no no fuck he stunned me oh I was
gonna shift I was gonna shift right click and he stunned me
out of my shift he actually stunned me out of my shift I'm
so sad it's okay I had it too
I have to use this what how did that not wipe it okay that's
fine this is fine I have to use this oh my god please I've
just made I just...
I...
I think he threw me up.
Alright.
It's okay.
You know what this means.
I have to do this for the res.
Okay, it's fine.
We have res.
At least.
We have the res.
Fuck you, Spider-Man.
That's right.
I ain't standing there.
That's fucking right You're not getting me this time Akami,
thank you for the right Thank you, thank you Hope you had a
great stream I'm just I'm Cues are definitely doomed right
now Cues are Cues are very doomed at this point
She's crashing out Um Well I had a few I told you guys This
year, this year is not a lucky year.
This year is not a lucky year for me.
I am definitely in loser queue.
I'm getting all the terrorists on my team, which is crazy,
because I'm supposed to be the terrorists.
But yet today, today they're like, you know what?
Wouldn't it be funny if you get all of them all grouped up
in one queue?
in one team.
It's like that.
What was it?
I don't remember what game it is.
But there's a rank, there's a game where if you get reported
too much, they put you in your very own queue system where
you put all the hackers and shitty players go into.
I remember that was a real thing that they did.
I forgot what game it was.
There was a game where if you get reported enough, they put
you, we put all the people got reported into one kill.
So, like, all the hackers and everything, which is funny.
There you go.
Okay, it hits me out of everyone else.
Wasn't like, did my entire team pass through that?
My entire team passed through it, but yet somehow I'm the
one that hit gets hit.
That's crazy.
That's actually Like, what is my luck?
I wanted to give it to him.
This is gonna be hard to push through.
It's gonna be very hard to push through.
We might be able to build...
Oh my god.
Aw, he's lucky.
Okay, I'm just gonna try and heal.
Oh hey, nice!
I don't have like any All right, look at that Wow, I thought
you said he was an atom one trick 600 plus hours That was a
fucking lie What happened to the 600 plus hour fucking atom
Oh my god, please I am trying my
I'm sorry, I really don't like my cloak.
I know it's not her fault, but like, I really, I am, it's
not her fault.
I just, I just don't like cloak right now.
Oh my God, let's hope he gets, oh my, Jesus Christ, please.
Kill them!
Please!
No one!
Oh my god.
Okay, we killed him.
We killed him.
Okay.
Okay, at least we fucking, ladies and gentlemen, we got him.
Oh my god.
Where's my cloak?
I'm trying so hard right now to stay alive to stay alive
right now I can't I can't stay alive here
like I swear to God I am not getting peeled but I'm gonna
stop I'm oh my god I don't want to say it but like I want to
that's the only reason why our cloak has lived so long is
because I am doing to peel for our cloak but i'm not getting
the same treatment which is crazy like oh look at that is
that is that peeling like like it's crazy oh my god it's
actually crazy
test but i'm doing everything i can to peel for him no tv no
tv after that point i can talk to i just need to gamble you
just need to gamble please you just gamble oh hey you saw
that you saw how the close didn't look at me there holy shit
oh that's crazy oh my god look at me oh
that's crazy that's like crazy that's all you're on your own
the thing the fuck the part is that i i do so much to help
our club but i don't get the same respect stand why don't
they why doesn't he respect me like I actually have to use
this thing yeah bye yeah I wish I know what it's like to
feel supported yeah oh man that sucks doesn't it Wow Wow
cook cook I
Damn cloak.
Is that crazy that you live?
That's insane That's actually insane that you live.
Wow It's like you know Somebody like save your life Make
sure you get me this like in spin Do you want to just get an
arm?
You're gonna like I'm Scary
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I'm just...
I'm using this to heal.
I'm not gonna point.
Jesus.
I got so well hit, but it's fine.
My cloak died?
How?
Let the cloak 20 miles away!
Oh my god.
I don't even know how my cloak died there.
I'm the...
Fuck, did my cloak die?
Oh my god, that's fine.
Jesus Christ.
That's crazy that my cloak died.
I took the Spider-Man 20 miles away from everyone.
So I was so surprised.
I was like, who fucking shot you?
killed you at that point.
I'm gonna use my... I have to heal.
I have to use this to heal myself because I can't trust
anyone anymore.
Oh my uh...
I'm literally using this.
Oh wow, that sucks buddy.
Oh my uh...
The fact that I have to use this to heal myself Okay, guys,
I need you guys to oh my god I need to gamble and go gamble
like you guys are just going in by yourself You must like
why is everyone staggering?
Oh my god, just me really go gamble and just win for free
like I don't know what the fuck Why were they all fucking
going in one by one?
All right, are we all here?
Are we all here?
Okay, they're stranger Let's go!
Oh my god, a fucking course.
A fucking course that happens to me.
All right, you know the drill.
It's time.
It's time to grab the res.
Oh my god, a fucking course is the Luna that gets the
fucking res.
A fucking course.
A fucking course that Luna gets the res.
Jesus Christ.
Like, who else would get it?
Oh, no.
All right.
Our Luna is alive.
Our Luna, Luna, please do not front line.
Please, please, please.
the guy i swear to god do not front line do not front line i
swear to god you do not need a front line like you do not
just to just oh my god it's okay it's me you don't need a
front line
god he's so dead he's so dead It's okay, it's okay, it's
okay We're so close to us Come on, guys
It's fine, it's fine We still have this
Please, just Just kill him Just kill him Just
Oh my god, please Oh Oh
You notice how I stopped peeling for the cloak and then the
and just played for my life And then the cloak suddenly had
so many got so many deaths after that Did you guys notice
that?
Did you?
That right after I After
After Okay.
Oh my god.
I have to avoid this cloak there.
I can't.
I can't do this again.
I cannot do this again.
I must have been a coincidence.
Or am
I mental?
I couldn't do this again.
um oh my god it was it was too much for me it was actually
too much i i was playing the babysitter but who was
babysitting me this was the most like amount of heals i had
to do on gambit because i always because like i had to i had
to rely on myself to heal and and and i had to use my e to
regenerate hp that was the worst part i the worst part was
because like usually i don't have to when you play gamut you
when usually usually you know when you get damage your
support would heal you but then i had to do this to heal
myself i i had to do that Oh, but that was not ideal.
That was absolutely not ideal.
I was not having a good time.
I
Oh my god.
I literally, I was a babysitter.
I, that cloak might have been like, wow, Gabba, you're
fucking terrible.
You're dying so much.
I'm like, yeah, you want to know why I was dying so much?
You, yeah, yeah, you want to, you want to know why?
Oh my god, that was crazy.
crazy that that was not not a fun time I wonder why someone
was like Tybo you made this wood three people oh yeah yeah
Mr Heroes oh my God it truly was fucking Mr Heroes right
there yeah I was gonna say guys we have the Adam was not the
issue uh they're like so worried about the fucking Adam one
trick and I'm like bro like the Adam was definitely not the
issue here you literally swapped off Adam he was not doing
anything
I can't believe that guy was afraid of the fucking Adam
if anything it was free yeah it was it was literally free
kills on the reses oh my guy oh oh Oh my god, at least like,
oh my god, at least, at least like everyone else, like by a
teammate sort of also realized that Cloak was not it.
Oh my god, I was so used to playing Gambit, I just, I'm
going on business now.
I'm going on business.
I'm a very important shark a vi s wait so I can do this with
all right let's see I'm coming over guys I want to be part
of this very important oh I guess not I guess not I want to
be part of this very important business meeting which hero
do you think you want to be today Luna, thank you for the
five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, a storm player?
What the fuck?
Why me?
Guan Guan sends...
Guan sends the agents to his strongest players.
He really does.
He sends his agents to the strongest players.
He knows I can take it.
He knows I can...
Who else would it be?
Jeff Nato is not broken.
Not in this Elo.
It's very easy to shut down Jeff Nato.
Scala, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to be disappointed.
Okay, actually, there's no way they can Make me more
disappointed There's no way I've already I've seen the I've
seen the void Oh my god, they've passed What the fuck Okay,
my turn Okay, what the fuck do I play?
Oh my god, am I actually gonna do Jeff?
Okay, maybe, okay, wait Maybe they won't play Mag No, I've
been and loser.
Okay.
Oh, Luna is so bad now.
It's such a... Oh, my God.
Wait, what the fuck is my team?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I... Okay.
Okay.
Guan Guan sends these players to the strongest.
Guan Guan sends them to the strongest players.
He knows.
He knows I'm fine.
He knows I'm already... I've been through so much already.
That none of this hurts me anymore.
That's your seen the void nothing can surprise me now he
does it to test me what do you do luna all the other
supports are just better but like i don't know i normally
would not play luna luna's like so bad now but it's like i
don't know i would play cloak cloak would be a better choice
but um if they have actually no actually cloak will not be a
better Yeah, they have mag.
Actually, no, they don't.
Wait, where the fuck is...
Where the fuck is...
Yeah, they don't have mag.
Wait, I can actually...
I can actually play.
Also, like, it's just a lot slower now.
Bro, okay, I'm trying.
I am actually trying so hard to heal.
You don't understand.
There's so many...
Oh, my...
Oh my god, you don't understand.
They're just all attacking us.
Okay, they're running Mantis Shark.
Oh god, we should not have run Rocket.
It's so slow.
Yeah, the heals are like a lot slower too.
It's a lot slower now too, the heals.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna...
Normally I...
Okay, guys.
We're not gonna live that.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hi, Kappa.
We have three DPS and yet none of them are fucking...
Okay.
Maybe I'll live here.
Okay, I like how our rocket didn't even try to heal me, but
that's okay.
Like, you know, it's my fault.
Oh, my...
Bye.
Yet somehow, we somehow got every character.
Except I was not going to win this fight.
That's crazy.
We got everyone.
We didn't even get like...
Oh my god.
You know what?
Fuck this.
It's Jeff Tapp.
Oh my god, he did it.
How did we not have a single?
that's crazy that it's okay it's not take going anywhere
nice oh my god guys please don't step into okay that's fine
that's fine I'm doing business I'm doing business right now
oh my god that's so embarrassing.
That is so embarrassing.
Hang on, please.
Please.
How how do we not get any of the players that played Scyloc?
Scyloc, we get the storm and the fuzzy spider.
Okay.
Oh My guy They take his ending At least like I'm doing
business though.
I'm doing business
Sight you're right yo the crazy part.
No, it's our storm guys.
It's not the spider.
It's the storm.
That's
the storm there was there was nothing we could do the
current score is yeah we have a storm
at least just pays taxes right bro what happened i don't
fucking know look at oh and then he instantly locks uh uh
start buying afterwards it's simple oh don't blame healers
oh Oh, don't play...
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
There, there we go.
Get on the fucky.
Okay, fine.
All right, let's go cloak then.
There it is.
Like clockwork.
There.
Oh, it's the healer.
fuck is that oh whoa whoa oh wow yeah wow i wonder how wow
you do oh there there it is
there we go
is a meta because of the healers.
Wow.
Whoa, I looked up, guys.
Guys, I looked up.
Is this what else?
Oh, my God.
No, I don't think nothing can save him.
That's for sure.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit, guys.
Okay.
All right.
This is awkward.
Wow.
The storm couldn't heal that way.
So if I never let go of left click, you can't fucking yell
at us for not healing.
Whoa.
Is that crazy?
I don't know what hit me.
Oh, my God.
It's the fucking widow.
Hey, guys.
Look at.
Wow.
Guys, guys.
I'm looking up.
I'm.
Oh, but who's good?
Oh, wow.
We all.
looked up guys wow
oh my god i fucking fucked that up man wow we looked oh man
wonder why everyone was asking heals everywhere in random
places
what what happened What happened to me?
Bro, I don't even- what the fuck?
Oh my god, I didn't even see them.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh My god.
Oh My god I'm so sexy.
I'm so sexy.
Okay, okay.
Whoa, I'm looking up!
I'm looking up!
There's no other ways for me to look at!
Oh my god, oh my...
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm still looking up.
You know what?
Let's use everything.
Let's fucking do it.
Thanks for the boost.
All right, guys, I can't believe it.
He was right.
We just gotta look up.
Who would have thought?
He was right all along.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He has this to fucking fight in.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're looking.
We have no support.
adults.
We have no support adults, guys.
No support adults, but that's okay.
I'm gonna be here.
I'm gonna be here so I can look up and heal here.
What the?
What the fuck?
Okay.
What was that?
Why were they on me?
Not just wait, I was bucky-doo!
I was like, oh my god, we did it.
We looked up.
Guys!
Did it!
We looked up.
We like did it.
Storm was right.
Who would have thought?
Damn
I don't feel like I won you didn't look up hard enough true
true I didn't look up hard enough and Bucky and widow
fucking both like me.
Oh and through that pain I get plus 17.
Yeah, that storm did not deserve to win that game.
No, my god Oh my fucking god.
Oh, I'm like I'm guys.
I'm dodging this queue.
I'm sorry You can call me a filthy Q dodger, but I'm not
playing that lobby again.
I am not playing that lobby again.
Now, I don't want any of them back there.
Oh, my God.
How much did the storm...
I bet you, like, plus 20-something.
I bet you.
I will never know.
I will never find you.
know I wish I did know but we'll never know we'll never have
the privilege to know oh my god how do you know DPS don't
think the DPS is all of it's all about me me me me me they
don't care about everyone they don't care oh my god that
fact that they're like, it's the support's fun.
I'm like, oh, okay.
Okay.
I was like, don't say it.
Like, okay, the moment he was like, what was it?
He was like, uh, wait, I wonder why they have support all
this first, guys.
Okay.
Here we go.
Where was it?
Oh, here you go.
It's simple.
The moment he was like, it's simple.
I was like, don't you say it.
Don't you there say it.
Don't.
Whoa.
Don't you fucking say it, bro.
And then he said it.
He fucking said it.
It's simple.
I knew where he was going the moment you said that.
No.
We're the most oppressed group in Marvel rivals.
I feel like support players get flamed the most, no matter
what.
Because it's like when the DPS fucks up their alt, they
don't, I mean they do, yeah, but like, I feel like DPS and
tanks, when they fuck up their alt, they don't get yelled as
much as when a support fucks up their alt.
More like...
Is that a 2-2?
Yeah.
It's here to give us a party.
But, but, uh...
But, but, but, uh...
I think that's why I haven't been playing a lot of rivals.
Um...
Also because I didn't get nominated, too, but, like...
There's no...
I mean, there might be correlation.
correlation why I haven't been streaming rivals too or like
playing it as much um um but like I just feel like the
players are much more toxic now than before like the other
seasons the other seasons like it's funny toxic but now it's
not funny no more now now it's just me
goba toxic but like they're allowed to talk to me like
they took out the funny yeah they took out the funny part of
the of being mean
hmm why is venom shaking it because we're q dodging have
they okay nice they're all out oh my god no they're not
they're not all out okay but like it's the storm oh my god
Wait, did I avoid the, I don't remember.
Did I avoid the storm?
I didn't, right?
Oh my god, they appear offline, aren't they?
Oh my god, this fucker.
This fucker is appear offline like a bitch.
Oh my god, third.
No, so he's like, no one can Q dodge me if I appear offline.
That fucking whore.
He's a pussy.
He doesn't even let me have the power.
privilege to cue dodge what a fucking pussy
that's fucked up that is so fucked up
he's a real that's like a professional agent he knows like
how many people avoid him because he's a storm like he knows
having people dodge him because he's a storm one trick the
point where he actually he's he's fucking the point where
where he's actually appearing offline.
That's full terrorism right there.
He doesn't even give us the privilege to Q-Dodge him.
He's like, you gotta find out yourself if I'll be in your
lobby or not.
Like, that's full-on terrorism right there.
Like, at least, like, you know, you know, you could at least
not appear offline.
Hiding like a landmine.
Yeah.
Like, the Q-Dodge.
trojaners q dodge where are my partiers oh hey oh hey here's
the second mantis too you get double the the show that's
right oh she's looking at both of us now that's what if i'm
through the backside all right here the double that's right
wait actually okay i got an idea you get the front and then
also the back there we go go now now there we go yeah double
the view all right soon oh god what are you doing here oh it
nice i like how i like the peeping tom over there too um the
peeping jeff everyone's fucking rolling up it's like whoa
dinner and show in time square wowie patrice do they give us
for the thousand.
I was going to say a super chat.
Thank you for the thousand videos.
Thank you.
What is your favorite one trick and why is it Mr. Fantastic?
The biblical levels agreed.
Oh my god.
It's crazy.
Like in one day too.
Like in the last I think like three to four yeah.
In the last four hours of playing I had five Mr. Fantastic
one tricks.
And like I've never went this far before like i've never hit
five mr fantastic one tricks before it's actually insane i
play this game for how long i play this game for so fucking
long and like oh she's crying tears of joy right now uh and
like that is like like yeah it's actually crazy and he's not
even meta that's the worst price he's nice i don't know
where they came from bro he wasn't even the one otp that guy
played fucking mag uh loki like jeff like where the what the
do you mean otp i was like thank god we didn't listen to the
fucking mr fantastic player oh shayariana grande don't you
have a press tour to do for wicked Oh my god, no, he's open,
Mike, as well.
You're a Viking, by the way.
Oh, and I can't open it.
All right, there you go.
Don't you have, like, a wicket to go to?
Yeah, real?
Oh my god, guys.
Real Arianna Grande in my Marvel Rivals lobby?
I am manning Daredevil.
Oh my god, speak up the devil.
Not Tim's, not Daredevil.
oh man it's him it's it's him i mean i guess i ban siloed
it's it's him guys oh my oh emma okay i mean we do have
venom only okay i Iron fist.
Okay, guys.
This is gonna win.
Okay, at least Mr. Fantastic didn't win.
Pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
I have Burger Billy.
Like, I don't know.
I'm not feeling much hope with Burger Billy.
For some reason, I'm not feeling much excitement over Burger
Billy.
Hey guys, just so you know, I'm team leader, so I'm just put
that out there.
I call dibs.
That'd be the co-captain or something.
Make a way for the king of thieves.
Uh, how much?
What's wrong with Burger Billy?
That 275k.
That's, we can make more of that.
Burger Billy, my goat.
That's why you're the captain.
I'm co-captain.
True.
The shader isn't loading yet.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Why are my shaders not loading?
All right, here you go.
Good.
Ray, thank you for the 10 gifts and subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
This might be rough.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Bro, I haven't had a real fucking cop.
Okay.
But like, to be fair, I gotta remember, it is 7 in the
morning.
I do not.
I should not expect that from my players.
I should not.
I should not expect that from these guys.
At this point, I'm just happy to be included.
I'm just happy to be included Oh that's why he wanted to ban
Iron Fist He has a, there's no way He has a third party app
There's no way he knows Like how did he know that They have
an Iron Fist player This guy was literally on streamer mode
Unless he's like ultra nerding Oh I'm not playing these guys
anymore
Alright All right.
Oh, no, bro, it's not fair.
It's not fair, guys.
It really isn't fair, guys.
Why do they get real players?
It really is quite crazy about that, you know?
Please heal me, please heal me, please heal me.
you're mr fantastic bro oh my okay it's fine okay okay okay
oh my god where where where is everybody yeah we're just
bouncing around okay okay Okay, this is not fair only
because they I what do I do
Bro, they they have fucking they have three support elements
what we have to What is guys guys, this is why I Oh
Why are we not?
Hey, literally.
It's okay.
That's fine.
You see what burns?
Okay, so...
You are fucking annoying.
Oh my god.
Guys, I told you I did not have much hope.
Yeah, GMP.
Yeah, for sure.
My bad, it's a lot of steel.
We got back in the box for a living.
Oh my god.
What do I ever do?
Come on, come on, let's go.
Let's go, guys.
Come on, guys.
We got it.
Guys, we got it killed, guys.
Oh, my God, guys.
Wow.
Guys.
Guys, guys, we got it killed.
Is that cool?
Oh, God.
Guys, I told you, it's not fun, toxic anymore.
This is what...
Oh, my God.
Shut the fuck.
Guys, guys, I told...
Never heard of you in my life.
I don't even want to ask him, bro.
I don't even want to ask him.
Never heard.
Never, never heard of you in my entire life.
Who's your favorite streamer?
Who's yours fucking quibbles?
You fucking faggot?
Jesus Christ, shut up.
Oh my god.
We flip back, wait.
Go for it.
Wait, is this Valentina?
That's not Valentina, right?
Oh, my life's over.
oh my god you're mad help what did i do to you bro what did
they do to you 30 seconds before you are we forfeiting or
what what's going on there goes y'all are low like nobody
knows you no shade check in any game ever check check my
peaks yeah peak check go for it i want to know his peak
immortal three radian no actually immortal three on my alt
count on Valorant and now my main so I don't want to play
with this game 88 oh mine's ranked six mine's higher they're
same wait Leslie Crow yours is higher let's look at rank six
rank one in Overwatch you can't read either can't read
either Leslie Crow Leslie Crow you just call me a slur
Leslie Crow yo you have to be like a for us Invis you have
to be for a hundred There's no way What the fuck?
Wait, why are we shit talking to the infus?
Wait, what's up, frog?
Bro, why are we slave?
Wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
Wait, so, so, wait, how is the infus in the wrong year?
What the fuck?
Bro, this guy sent a slender and an impulse with a hat.
All my teammates.
Sorry, I can't see you in this.
What the fuck did he in this dude?
So what do you say about Valentina?
You gotta be him.
Yeah, I think that's it.
No, it's not mine.
Bro, what?
What?
I'm sorry.
Why do you even need that?
No one knows you are.
Oh my god.
I could literally Oh, she's friends with Valentina Oh, she
pulled the She pulled the I know all the gold Hey, oh my god
Guys, I told you Guys, I told you guys Nothing good comes
from a name called Burger Bill a game nothing good comes
from a game from your team when one of them is called burger
billy i knew it i knew it i i called it guys i'm like i
called it i saw it's not talking it's not talking
Guys, I told you nothing good comes from my team
What is going on?
Bro, are we doing better when people started slurring?
Yo, bro, what did they do to you?
How did you just wake up?
Like how did you just wake up?
What?
I feel fine.
Did he just say how you wake up?
Ask your dad, you know.
Bro.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, this punsa.
That punsa was so bad.
Oh, that's good.
That's a mad bull.
Oh, bro, he's dead.
Oh, my God.
I mean, we've gone over there.
Bro.
No right.
We literally went over there.
Right?
Guys, I told you...
This game is...
No...
You got soft hands, brother.
Good shit, brother.
I like how the only people laughing are the people you're
playing with.
I'm never gonna die alive.
Yeah, my buddy, I'm still with you.
It's all right.
We did.
Yeah.
I just get 3ds Harley Kirk's on my team.
Maybe I wish you were Charlie Kirk.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Russians, honey.
Please!
Please come back again!
Right here.
Baby, your president sucks car.
Oh my god, please tell me I'm safe.
Am I safe?
I'm so bad.
Oh my god, he relocated again.
No trolls.
Wait, guys, okay, you guys didn't hear...
Okay.
Okay, like, you guys didn't hear the invasals either, right?
Like, I'm not going crazy, right?
Wait, I don't know if I started playing better once the game
is done.
stop speaking a little bit i've been speaking the entire
fucking round i don't think they realize i'm streaming i
don't think they realize i am the streamer in the sloppy
right now i because i feel like if they know who i was who
is Currently, like, on the front, on the top of the rack, I
don't think they would say all of this stuff.
I don't think they have, oh, oh my gosh.
Maybe no one cares.
Overwatch is dead.
This is insane.
I'm a grown-ass man talking about peaks in a video game.
Go to work.
You're the one, you're the one, Keith.
Guys, I told you, I saw Burger Billy, and I knew this team.
I knew it was going to be one of those games.
I knew it.
It's not like the individual Burger Billy.
It's more so, like, the vibe of the team I was going to get.
You guys were like, what's wrong with Burger Billy?
And I was like, no, guys, I had the vibe.
Like, I had the vibe.
I saw Burger Billy, and I was like, bro, I...
Wait, why didn't he bring it to the peak again?
Didn't go enough, man, by the way.
You're a little boy.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
That's how your dad's into those, though.
Wait, this game pedal?
Yeah, you gotta be.
Oh.
Oh, at least we contested a little bit, right?
I didn't think...
Oh, my God.
No, we weren't living.
It's okay.
We got the Scythe.
We got the Scythe and the Iron Fist.
Oh, God.
Guys, we did it.
Maybe Val don't know you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Do your real voice, do your real voice.
I'll don't know you, sir.
Okay.
I know so.
Maybe?
Goodbye.
Yeah, I got you.
Oh my god.
I mean, I'm not opening that.
Why?
Why won't you alt this?
Why didn't you alt this?
What did I do to you?
We're all together the entire time.
You have to come out of your IP.
You can't see it.
Why did I shoot at you?
Never.
Oh my god!
I understood!
I didn't deserve this treatment!
Oh my- Don't get- Oh, we won.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
It's no longer fine.
It's no longer fine It's no longer fine.
Okay, bitch.
I didn't say shit about you I Don't fucking give my toxicity
to me.
I didn't say nothing to you like I if anything I'm defending
you on my own stream
I'm like what the fuck bro?
What are you being mean of me for?
Oh man, if only we had...
Okay, I'm spying.
Wait, why did I get friendly fire?
What do you say fuck me for?
Guys, can you guys start being angry at each other again?
You guys perform better when you're angry at each other.
That's all I'm saying.
Like for some reason, you guys do better when you're all
angry at each other.
And like, please, please start yelling at each other again.
I really appreciate if you guys can yell at each other
again.
Because for some reason, you guys stop talking and now we
lose.
Guys, I need you guys to start talking again.
Oh my oh my god.
Okay, it's five It's no longer five.
It's no longer five.
It's no longer five guys guys guys.
Oh my god.
I Oh Oh my god, if he's clock it clock it.
Yes, sir Fuck it rock it still negative by the way Oh, okay
That's my inbox right there.
Lock it.
Lock it, bitch.
See you later.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're about A-O, bro.
You're actually better than A-O-O.
Oh, my God.
Well, you can't expect it from now.
Oh.
All right, I'm just gonna go with my gut that they all
avoided each other.
I'm just gonna assume.
Oh, hey, Burger Billy gave me a thumbs up.
I'm just gonna assume that they all avoided each other.
So...
I hope we all learned.
The thing is...
The thing is, for those who don't know,
when you're Celestial, you can't do more than duo.
So one of these guys is an actual solo player.
I can assume that maybe these three are trioed, and then
this guy is the solo.
But they all still ganged up on this guy.
guys i told you guys rivals now is is very funky now i told
you now rivals now is it's in a very weird state in rank
what did ariana grande do to deserve this the second movie
was pretty mediocre not gonna but um anyway so i think what
started it was ariana grande it was like criticizing our dps
for not doing anything because you know uh um because they
sort of weren't at first while like i was like doing so much
of healing and keeping my team alive and then i gambit
altered punishment and we still didn't kill anything and And
then so Ariana Grande was like, guys, come on.
And then, and then I think like Billy Burger or Burger Billy
was like, what's up with your fucking voice?
And then you're like, you sound annoying.
And then it all went downhill after that because he had a,
because Ariana Grande had a very flamboyant voice and, and
then gamer word, gamer slurs started coming out.
and then um and and then they started talking about their
rank peaks and then apparently they're like yeah i was rank
one in overwatch and then i'm like i i don't know if i can
believe him because if you're rank one in overwatch why the
are you here in gm i was like why was why is your account in
gm i don't know maybe it's an ult account i mean i could
check right now oh never mind Not right now.
I unfortunately could not check right now.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Yeah, it all started because Ariana Grande, because they did
not like Ariana Grande's.
And then, okay, but then like, and then Ariana Grande
started dragging me too.
And then if I was like, what the, I didn't even say anything
to you.
Like, why fuck me for?
I didn't even say anything to her
She was like She was criticizing like how I was playing
But I was like Bro what?
I saved your life so many times I was like I was like what
the fuck I saved your life
I told you, guys, I knew the vibe.
That moment I saw Burger Billy, I knew, you guys doubted me.
You're like, what the fuck is wrong with Burger Billy?
And I was like, no, you don't understand.
That's the name of someone that's the name of someone that's
going to start something.
I felt it.
I knew they were going to start something.
And I was right.
I was right.
I knew that team was going to explode.
like at character select I just didn't realize it was a
nuclear bomb
I was not ready for the bomb so go ahead and happy thank you
for the twitch prime thank you thank you all right I mean
this is a spider-man map at least
What is the Asian this time?
Is either our... It's, uh, actually...
It could be our Spider-Man.
This is a Spider-Man map, but it could always be the
Spider-Man.
Guys, uh...
Bucky, that was very scary, Bucky.
Oh my God.
Okay, guys, we gotta start shooting this.
Guys.
Guys, we gotta start oh my god guys we have to start
shooting things guys guys please we gotta start shooting
things i do not have enough damage output for this oh
my god i couldn't anti him i didn't have the cards why did
you pull him when i didn't have the cards
actually be our spider-man.
I told you it's always... it's a hit or miss.
It's always a hit or miss.
It doesn't matter if it's a spider-man map.
Okay, okay.
Um, it was our spider-man.
It was, it was, guys.
Oh my god, he had to use healers for that.
I don't like that.
Alright, let's go.
I'm not.
Here we go.
Oh!
What the fuck?
What the- Okay.
Okay, guys, we gotta kill this guy at least.
All right, at least we killed him All right, there we go
Gambit never falls That's the only way, apparently Okay, I
have to save this All right We got us I'm saving my stuff
Because I can feel Okay There we go There we go I don't have
another one.
If he groups off, we're fucked because I don't have another
one.
All right, here we go.
I'm sorry, I don't have another.
Okay, it's okay.
We're not fucked.
Guys, I was able to build it up in time.
Here we go.
Guys, we did it.
I built it up in time.
Thank God he delayed it.
He delayed it.
Thank God.
That was good.
I got the card just in time.
I have to, like, be aware.
Be active.
Okay, I can technically...
Yeah, what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah, fuck this guy in particular.
Fuck it.
Oh, fuck.
Nope, not.
No longer.
Whoa!
Okay, yeah, let's go.
Let's party, everyone.
Alright, so I have a feeling that the sidewalk is gonna try
and kill us all.
Just a little feeling.
Oh my god, alright.
Oh, goodbye, Spider-Man.
Um, who's pushing?
Okay.
Oh, no, oh, good luck, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh, they used everything.
That's fine.
That's fine by me.
That's like what they used?
Phoenix, Invis, and Gambit, and Scyloc.
That's, you know what?
I take those.
Like I knew that was in Winnebeth.
So like I'm fine with that.
Like I'm so fine with that.
All right, that's good.
Okay, I know our Spider-Man is trying to have an epic 1v1
with the Gambit, and he lost.
Okay, okay, I need you to heal.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, he's fucking stupid.
That's, thank God.
Thank God, okay.
Thank, okay, thank God.
Oh, and they have Penny.
Okay, that's cool.
Alright, I had a feeling he had Scylocal and I was very
scared.
But that's okay.
We made it.
We fucking made it.
Oh, he blocked it?
Fucking bitch.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
They're not pushed up enough me that oh my god oh my god
okay i still have this look if the moment it don't worry
don't worry we are so healthy okay we can technically go
forward with this there you go i i wiped it
oh my god i don't have i don't have it for group i don't
have it for group i don't have it Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Okay, I have it for Groot.
I have it for Groot.
Oh, he's not Groot.
He's not Groot.
Okay, I don't have to care.
Alright, it's fine.
I don't have to care.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh my god, we couldn't feel him.
It's okay.
I can still reload.
There you go.
I didn't get him, but it was close enough.
Um, Spider-Man, good luck.
Good luck, Spider-Man.
Good luck.
I hope he lives.
I really hope our Spider-Man lives.
Okay, our Spider-Man's okay.
That's good.
What is going on up here?
Bro.
I swear to Spider-Man.
Spider-Man.
Like, are you okay?
I don't need to use this yet.
Okay, guys, you didn't see me miss that.
Okay, we don't need to use this yet.
You know what would have saved me there?
If I...
It's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's so terrible.
It's all right.
It's okay.
Oh, it's no longer okay.
This is last fight.
Guys, we have to touch.
Don't worry.
Our group will touch.
Our group is heading there.
He's gonna be a hero.
He's a hero.
Shh.
He really is.
Oh, my God.
He actually is a hero.
Oh my god, where's my invis?
I don't know where she is.
And I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, someone has to touch.
No!
I was so close.
He will not see nine.
Famous last words
Famous last words he will not see night
Oh man, I hate to break it to you but something happened
Something fucking happened guys I hate to break it to you
I look, thank you for the videos, thank you, thank you.
How do I pull my girlfriend away from Gambit?
She already lowered Jesus Christ.
I'm sending an email to Gwongo and nerf him to the ground.
That's all you can do.
Send an email to Gwongo and then pray.
And he'll change Gambit.
I don't even know where I can play.
Alright.
No, just nerf him.
I don't care.
I'm tired.
of how strong Gambit is.
Be fair.
That was fun to play.
But I'm already bored with the meta.
You know, we had too much of a good thing.
I'm greedy.
I'm already bored.
That's right.
Oh my god.
I don't like that to play so ahead.
I don't like that.
I don't like that I have to save this for heals because i'm
scared of my team i don't think my oh my god oh my god like
like i said like i said i have to just use this for heals
because my team is not okay right now
oh my god if i self heal then i won't i'll live at least
Are we stacked?
We are.
Okay, that's good.
That is good.
There we go.
Okay.
I don't want to be there.
We're still- it's still in them.
All right.
Let's go.
Okay, maybe I didn't have to use that.
I got scared.
Oh my god.
I- okay, that's good.
Nice.
We got the kills we need.
To secure it.
Look, I- I got scared.
Maybe I should have saved it.
Maybe.
But you don't understand.
I was very scared.
Okay, I gotta save this for it.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
I have to save this for a cleanse.
This looks like a fucking good old situation right now.
I'm gonna try and let our invis heal more.
That's good.
I don't have cleanse.
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I didn't have cleanse.
The one time I didn't have cleanse.
The one time.
Let me touch.
I don't know.
We can't touch.
There's no way.
Oh, hey, nice.
At least, I guess?
Okay.
Bro.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh, I'm sorry, bro.
I tried my best.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, we're gonna go in.
I don't care about my bucky.
We're gonna go in.
Like.
Fuck this.
Let's go.
See, alright, that's fine.
We got the Invis out from...
That's fine.
Okay, I don't know about the Spider-Man out, but that's
fine.
We got the Invis all out.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Look at that.
See?
Look at.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
That was a good trade.
Good trade.
That's the trade I'm willing to take, guys.
Yeah, I'm just...
Oh, that's unlucky.
I saved my thing now.
Okay, I gotta save the cleanse.
I feel it.
Okay, I'm just making sure that we can all...
Oh, nope, no more cleanse.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I couldn't cleanse that.
There was no way I could cleanse that.
Um, I think it's...
a spotty issue guys i told you guys guys i did say you're
like who's the e-o-m-m agent guys i i told you it can only
it's always this it's always a spider bat even if it's a
good map it's always spider bat
use this.
Fuck yeah, I have to use it to you.
Alright.
There you go.
That was a lot of up though, which I did not like because we
did not trade anything for it.
Oh wait.
Except for Invisal.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
I think our team is better technically, but we're 5v6 right
now.
It is technically better, but it is still a 5v6.
What the fuck was he fighting?
Okay, I tried.
I really did try.
Oh my god, that was an explosion.
Guys, I think we're losing because of our Spider-Man.
slash fire lord
oh my god i literally got him out of here wait what he
fucked it up nice nice okay how did he get here what oh my
god how did we let him get here what thought guys guys how
did we let them free push it All the way here.
I am very concerned, team.
I am very concerned that we let them here.
I am very, very concerned.
Okay, well, I have to go early now.
I have to make sure.
Okay.
I am.
All right.
Okay, ready?
Okay.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, wait, what?
Wait, why?
Oh my god.
Why did you do not alter?
Wait, wait, oh my god, wait.
Why did we do not alter?
Wait.
Wait, wait,
why did we?
Wait.
Okay, but there is hope.
There is hope.
Second, second, second, second, second, second, second,
second.
Oh.
Oh, oh my god, I kept all my cards.
I kept all my cards.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I saved the team.
I actually saved the team.
I, oh my god.
I actually, I saved the game.
I saved the game.
I had both my cards and I just spammed all the cards on
here.
I knew I knew they had I knew they had fucking Oh my god.
I knew they had Scythe Lock.
I pulled out Royal Flesh.
all right i'm sorry about the food feed but you you're out
of here wait not not out of the game sorry i meant uh i'm
not reporting you i'm not out of the game not out of the
game but i'm just not on my team just oh my god oh my god i
can't oh my god that's crazy that we won that game that was
crazy it was really a 5v6 i felt like i was in a 5v6 fucking
area here oh they they've been muted nice oh my god all
right Oh, hey, Rigsie's back on.
All right.
Are you down for more?
Or are you working?
All right.
While we see if he replies, I gotta pee.
So you know what that means.
Up your back.
I gotta pee.
Oh, shit, nice.
All right.
get in here or I get in his lobby.
Alright, the best part the best thing about it is that he's
Celestial 1 and I'm Celestial 3.
So he'll lose more and I gain more.
That's my favorite part.
W.
Right there.
That's so fucked.
He consented to saying with me guys he consented it's not
fucked up if he consented
uh what time how i've been streaming for i know like i was
like oh i'm gonna rest a little i'm gonna rest but i got the
fire ignited in me no he does he does because i was playing
with him earlier and who was it was really bad it was just
as bad it no you don't guys don't understand it was really
fucking bad like like i went through a lot too on like he
was like bro you it he was like bro anda is fucking sucks
man what the fuck are your lobbies and then we queued eu and
they were so bad they were it They were worse than, um, than
my, the NAQs, and I was like, I, Rixie, I don't, Rixie, I
don't think NA, oh my god, let's all, oh my god, it's a
venom party, let's go, oh my god, let's go, finally a dream
come true, wait, what, it's fucking interrupted us, there we
go, wait, we gotta be cheek to cheek, guys, like, the venom
went, cheek to cheek, guys, Cheek to cheek.
Who keeps enter?
Okay, okay, okay.
Who the fuck is doing that?
Who is doing that?
Okay, cheek to cheek.
It's got it.
There we go.
I found my home.
I did it.
We're having a real party now.
I'm free to add.
Peaches to peaches.
Exactly.
That's the way to go.
go
very good all right what you do you think you want to be
today all right
don't please don't yell at me
i'm just please don't yell at me team that's all i want as
long as my team doesn't yell at me we're five just
don't yell at me
if they yell you exert yourself please don't yell at me i'm
just a little guy bro i'm so sad i'm so sad i didn't i
didn't realize how cool the fortnite event was i'm so sad
that they're fucking miku fucking got up at top of godzilla
and did the miku miku beam And then, like, apparently they
did it, like, Avengers-style.
It's, like, everybody was there.
Literally, everyone was there.
I didn't realize it was gonna be so sick!
I wouldn't fucking walk- fucking did a live-watch party!
Bro!
Yeah, the King Kong and Godzilla beat up some fucking
monster.
I don't fucking even know.
And then it was, like, 6-7.
Chapter 6 to 7?
I was like, oh my god.
I believe they did that.
They actually made it.
They made a 6-7 jump.
Stop!
Because it was chapter 6 to 7.
Oh, they killed the button.
Who the fuck is going to report?
Are we not going to be transported by buses now?
Who will we think now?
Also, apparently, what's his name?
uh nick uh was doing a live watch party at the kill bill
event and then like you know how he's like family friendly
like he's like so i he's that i i don't know how they he's
like a fucking kid show entertainer like a kid show host you
know how he's like no swearing and shit like that but he's
playing fortnite too so it's like how the fuck does he do
that and then like but like there was a kill bill event and
they were all started swearing everything and he was like
Wow!
Like, I'm fucking... Like, oh, it's so weird.
Because he's, like, 31.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my... Sorry, I was... Sorry, I'm too busy gossiping.
My bad.
I was gossiping.
Oh, my god.
I'm trying my best.
We can kill him, right?
But not one behind us.
Oh, my...
We did, we did, we did.
I spammed it.
I need you to know, I have...
I indeed spammed...
Guys, I don't know if this is winnable.
Oh, my God.
How did I miss that?
It went through his goddamn nigs!
It's okay.
I have it up soon.
Right here.
The moment we're all...
Are we all here?
Oh my god, we better be here.
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
It's okay.
I died for the cause.
We still won the fight, guys.
Not our Emma though.
Our Emma might be dead.
Our Emma's definitely dead.
Our Emma's not living that.
No, 100%.
Our Emma is absolutely fucking dying to that.
Alright, it's fine.
Brigsy.
Hello.
Hello there.
Okay.
We got this together, Loki.
Loki, we got this together.
Alright.
Alright, that's...
I think I cleared everything for us.
I think...
See, look, look, everything is fine.
Alright, here we go.
Where are you?
What the...
Where are you, Rixie?
Oh.
Where are you at?
Where you at?
There's no way to make it in time, right?
Yeah, there's no way.
That's gonna be very concerned.
Alright, it's okay.
It's not, but like, I like to cope sometimes.
And by sometimes, I'm...
It's nearly my entire...
Loki, I am trying my best.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There you go.
Okay.
I'm not gonna pee.
Nice.
We did it.
Look at us.
Guys.
Peace.
Guys, please.
Thank you.
Guys, I'm not winning that 1v1.
I need help.
I need assistance.
I'm from the A.
I demand no honor.
Oh my god.
I do not want honor.
It's okay.
I don't need honor.
I just want to live.
I'm going to try and, like, make that art.
Okay.
I'm just trying to...
Aw.
That's unlucky.
Hey, guys.
How does he get?
Get me from there!
Okay, give me a sec.
Come on, guys.
You're going to win this fight, right?
Let's get, let's get.
Did he hit him?
Oh my god.
Okay, hit him.
Hit him.
Okay, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
Oh my god.
No, I thought I went out of the circle.
That's why I was like, where am I?
I thought it was outside.
A circle is a circle.
That is not a...
That should not be part of the circle.
Jesus Christ.
What?
Okay, there we go.
Arlo keys.
Okay, that's fine.
What the fuck?
I'm too scared to go back deep in.
Too scared.
I've seen what happened to me.
Okay.
Came all the way to Europe.
All right, here we go.
The circle.
Oh, I missed that.
I didn't want to weigh in these logs too.
All right, here we go.
It's fine.
Oh, he went back to...
Okay, I'm gonna use that.
Okay, I'm gonna stand in front now.
I'm here to help.
Okay, I'm just gonna say it.
This is cyberbullying.
This is cyberbullying right now.
This is every time.
Every fucking time.
I get solo alted.
There's a cyber bullying
Like why the thing is he's he thinks I'm the Loki Gambit
That's the worst part Because he's trying to kill the Gambit
off He's trying to kill the Gambit off But yet somehow He
always picks the wrong Gambit He always picks me
He's like, this has to be the low-key gambit that altered
just now.
But it's always me.
Because when you kill the gambit, the gambit all stops.
Like every supporter.
But somehow he always picks the wrong gambit.
And it happens to be me every time.
Oh, okay, I'm good.
I'm okay.
I'm defeating, but at what cost?
Why is it always me?
He lost the gambit.
He lost the 50-50 three fucking times!
I think I'm fucking leaving.
I got my fucking thing.
Jesus Christ.
There you go Oh my what there you go.
I'm with you I'm with you
All right, I got reload don't work.
Oh my oh, that's that's awkward.
That is very awkward.
I don't have anti to
I'm very scared.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
Um.
Okay.
All right.
Me and the Gampit.
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
I literally looked away for one second.
And then my Loki died.
That's crazy.
My Loki died so fast.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I don't like this game anymore.
There's too much damage, and I don't like that.
Alright.
Are we all here?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, this is...
Okay, I don't know where to go.
after that okay that's good we're even technically also
where the fuck is that guy where is he oh he won the 1v1 at
least okay did we stop the vehicle guys can we it'll be
pretty cool we stop the vehicle guys okay okay we won
technically we won the fight i take those
Okay, look.
I am trying so hard to keep you up.
Oh, I thought you was to my right.
I gambit wrong.
It was a rock.
Oh my god.
I'm like, just feel like I'm schizo right now.
Please tell me we hit that.
Oh, thank god.
It's okay.
Okay.
Okay, you fucking freak.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that all?
It's a fucking freak.
I would come in this way.
That was personal.
That was actually personal.
No.
100 percent 100 are my text real clear no no they are not
what i saw no they are not i saw some crazy shit just now
with that venom up oh
i didn't get that oh no no no no okay
why did he survive okay he died too he died too okay good
good he died as well okay okay i was gonna freak out if he
has lived yet again okay
okay we have to oh my god stop going stop going what what
i come back with my goals okay and we come back with silo
goals if you live all right I had that silo That was my bad
I positioned wrong there Keep touching Rick second Oh no
Okay I threw that I positioned to the right And I didn't
think I'd get fucking Ran at That was my bad I should have
positioned there
You know what's crazy?
He was definitely not trying to He was definitely not trying
to aim for me I mean that's the crazy part tell me yet
please oh okay okay that's good that is good wait is the
hawk still alive okay i was like did we leave him alive oh
my god we actually lived that was the first dialogue i've
ever lived stacked together.
Now, I, I, I never knew what that felt like until now.
Like, we finally stacked up.
That's crazy.
We actually stacked up together.
What the?
Okay, um, I hope that it got people.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I literally saw my life flash before
me, but it's okay.
I'm going to let my low-key heal.
I'm going to let him heal.
I'm going to...
I saw like 20 people trying to kill me.
Okay, I'm just going to hope I...
Okay, I have to use that.
You're welcome, mind for this fight.
Oh no.
I didn't heal because I wanted us to...
Okay.
Okay, that is an insane anti right there.
Oh my...
Please!
Oh!
Oh, I did it.
All I did it was one for you.
It's okay, I have a suit.
Okay.
Alright.
We
have...
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm not even gonna go up, I'm not.
Oh my god, where the fuck is that sila?
I see sila.
Okay, almost outside.
Raptor, raptor, raptor!
Watch out, watch out.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to keep you up.
Come on, come on.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I think I gambitled to that too early.
I don't understand.
Why is it always me?
I definitely...
play gambit all too early there i thought like oh we're all
here we just run forward we should i should wait i should
wait just like five more seconds oh my god i don't know what
i'm just gonna play for the like flat lanes i'm just gonna
shoot the dps oh my god like i just keep getting targeted
i don't know what to do i don't know what to do i don't i
don't know i just i can't do it nobody stacks for some
reason i just it's actually crazy oh my god i fucked up it's
fine i can build a card back up here yeah all right Starts
in five.
All right, here you go.
There you go.
Oh my god, it's five.
It's five.
Agua.
I'm on.
Body block.
Okay.
Here we go.
I anti that, but I don't know if that would be helpful.
Agua.
I'm blocking those.
Oh, my.
Come on.
I don't have a weapon.
Are you serious?
I'm trying to kite as much as I can.
Oh, my.
Oh my god.
There's nothing I could do.
They've just built Gambit up so much faster.
Do
you just go with our Gambit?
Yeah, we're not going to.
Okay.
Come on, I'm on.
I'll go on my Gambit.
I swear to God.
do it do it go go we're all it's everything everything just
everything oh my god time to switch things up including
which side you're on oh my god we had these every oh okay
the only concern was that we had a very rough time pushing
first point that is my concern we had a very rough time
pushing first point
it's never again it's never rocket time because because it's
always gambit time if we don't play gambit you lose
oh the worst part is that i can't dps because i know i have
to heal I swear to God, our tanks are sponges.
They're actual sponges.
Like, look at...
Look at...
Our tank...
One of our tanks is literally 14 deaths.
He's a fucking goddamn fucking damage sponge.
Like, I literally can't DPS.
Okay, we could...
You know, as I say, I could be extra sweaty and pull up
Rocket and give us armor and then come out as Gambit.
Three, two, one!
Jeez!
Oh my god, I got the fuck with that!
Jesus!
I can't!
I literally...
Hurry off that.
I got blount.
Maglo, Maglo.
Maglo.
Walking home.
Okay.
And here we go.
It's a down, but I'm gonna like corner.
item one i i i'm tied in
oh my god i don't have body block body block oh my i almost
had mag one mag one now you do the same for me we watch your
nails watch your nails okay
nice Oh my god.
Oh my god, he accidentally copied Mag.
He accidentally copied Mag.
Oh my god, I just noticed.
And then I missed my anti.
Please tell me that.
Please tell me that heals too.
Please, please, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Oh, they're running triple those fuckers They're running
triple Oh my god No wonder it feels like they're unkillable
Oh my god Oh my god I'm behind, I'm behind Oh my god.
We wiped it twice!
Oh my god, triple support!
Triple support.
Okay, I'm gonna have to let our low-key heal.
Our low-key, I see you.
Just copy and go with Gambit.
You might need to like look for the atom.
He's probably hiding.
This automaton must complete its mission.
The final 10 seconds.
There you go.
heal now i'm on it i'm on it technically
they're on the outback one thousand in the fucking outback
there they're for trouble i'm on point luna luna luna i'm a
one on point i'm a one on point I like one.
I like that.
I'm still one.
Okay.
Oh no, they have Gambit never fought.
Please stop.
Oh my god, please.
Watch me out.
Turn below.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I couldn't do anything.
They had triple support.
What did we do with that?
Oh my god.
It's just triple support.
Triple support is just so broken.
I didn't even get a final blow.
I was getting harassed non-stop.
Oh, I hate that.
that they went triple like there's nothing we could do
i was just i just kept getting hard targeted and no one
stacked up in the side lock up no one stacked up in the side
lock up so i always died to it every time every time because
he would just solo all me every time no triple support is
always the strongest cop They went triple support and it
worked for them It just sucked Our Loki copied mag To During
that one fight that we needed him on Gambit Every time And
then the fucking Emma The Emma and Silo were chasing Me
everywhere during the Did you guys see that?
The Emma ran past The mag past the point To fight me off
point And was just chasing me everywhere Yeah, during the
last fight.
Like, I don't know where to position.
They were all just running at me.
That was crazy.
Yeah, and then my entire team, half the team was in the
front.
One on the cart.
Okay, no, majority of the team was in the front.
One in the cart, me at the back.
And then the Emma was like, she's alone.
She's like, you're mad cat, leave the car or she'll see
nine.
It's crazy.
I was just like, pro, leave me alone, please.
Leave me the fuck alone.
I'm just, I'm just one of five.
And then, and then after I ran away from the Emma, I, oh
yeah, that one, that one.
part uh during defense when i went high ground there was a
sidelock i went down there was a hug i turned around there
was the phoenix and i was like where do i go
i just literally like where do i go why are they all here
for me like i swear to god i was like
all surrounding me yeah all paths somehow led to death right
there back to time square at least time square will make me
happy hello code cheek to cheek time don't worry this will
bring me joy come Join.
Oh, no fun.
Report this, Jeff.
What the fuck is this?
That was a dude.
Oh, wait, he's taking me out of bounds.
Bro, you fucking, you fucked it up, bro.
Bro, you fucked it up.
Cheek to cheek.
Wait.
Come on, come on.
Come on, cheek to cheek.
Peaches to peaches.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Cheek to cheat.
Right here.
Yeah.
This brings me joy.
I have felt...
Oh, shit.
Keep joy.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Come on, come on.
Yes!
Keep made a circle.
Oh.
This Jeff.
I wish you can turn on friendly fire mode.
You should be allowed to turn on friendly fire mode too.
It's time square.
Boo!
And that, Jeff.
He's ruining a good time.
Me and the other Venom were vibing.
Oh my god, we're back.
Oh my god, it's literally the same fucking team.
don't do this to me i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna get more
tissue to blow my nose up your back i mean it's just outside
i had to check out that on the stream but all right don't
honestly get the get siloed out of this game i don't care i
don't care rocket okay okay okay yeah like yeah we're not
letting that rocket bang go through yeah Oh, thank God.
That's just like, do not let this man speak for us.
Do not let him speak for all of us.
Oh, and then he picks Mag.
Okay.
I was going to say, do not let this man speak for us.
I do not consent.
All right.
Does anyone else want to play Gambit?
Gambit.
Does anyone else...
want a gambit?
Gambit?
Come on, gambit's pretty cool.
Anyone?
Anyone else?
All right, rocket tap.
Look, I am not solo supporting us, Gambit.
Like, I refuse.
I refuse the support okay well i guess i guess it's gambit
time what happened to the rocket band we won oh man i wish
you would play loki loki would be so much better
what oh my gosh sometimes i don't know how i missed that
like there was literally 20 oh my god
unlucky there we go that's the chat should be everyone that
i auntie
okay i just want to make sure that i
just want to make sure that we're okay all right it's okay
we're fine right i come down and i'll come down to assist us
down here
Okay, goodbye, Mac.
Goodbye.
Please, please, I protect you.
You protect me.
That is the circle of life.
Do you believe in the circle of life?
Please, please, do you believe?
Oh, yeah.
No, no, he...
No, that was a lot of ults.
That, that, that was, that was a lot.
Oh, my God, he's back.
He's fucking back.
It's him again.
Just walk the Luna off now.
Oh, okay.
How come he...
Why did they all leave me?
Why?
Why did they leave me?
I...
Thanks, Luna.
Yeah, I...
Hmm.
that vehicle moving again
that that hmm I didn't like that only 60 seconds left I did
not like that at all what the fuck how did he get okay bye
how did he there if so you can just go to guess i'll go mine
guys this does not look good how the fuck did their gamut
get up so fast well it didn't really help that uh you know
um oh my god
I didn't want to use that, but...
Yeah, we gotta walk here.
99 need here.
I'm just out of here.
Oh,
are you fucking kidding me?
There's nothing I could do.
There's...
Our Luna took up all the heal so I couldn't I couldn't build
my all-in tab The current score is I literally was trying to
build my all and then
And then our Luna took all the heals
How is this so painful?
You see Rixie told me that he you is better for Q's I'm
starting to believe he lied to me.
I'm starting to really believe that.
I don't think EU was it in the end.
I'm pretty sure he lied to me.
It's like, also like, why did they all left me to die?
Like, I don't understand.
understand that.
Also, why did we aggressively Luna ult?
Who told her to do that?
Yeah, and then when I aggressively support her, I get yelled
at!
I don't understand!
How come, like...
How come, like, they aggressively Luna ulted, support ulted,
and then...
And yet...
I get yelled at for doing the same thing.
Okay.
this is discrimination right there goodbye
yeah i i don't know what like i like luna luna i why it was
you knew he was gone bro that guy was being thrown off the
cliff luna i don't know why you thought you thought you
could save him i Oh no.
That was crazy that...
That's crazy that you thought...
That that was salvageable.
Oh my god.
My god.
I... there's nothing I could do.
There's...
He's actually the...
What do I?
What do I do?
Me and the Luna, we were just pocketing each other 24-7.
Like, I don't know.
I...
Final score.
0-2-1.
At least they didn't yell at me.
Yay!
When you cleanse any movement, I don't think I had the cards
yet.
I don't know.
I don't think I had the cards.
Miser, thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you.
I didn't get yelled at, guys.
That's a plus.
No one yelled at me?
Yeah.
I told you.
EU ain't it.
Cursed.
I think I've lost more on EU than I have in LA.
Uh, do they have time to get water?
I'm gonna get water.
I think I have time.
I'm gonna book it.
I'll be right back.
Guys, guys, now I forgot to give you guys a show.
Now I'm gonna book it.
Mega, thank you for five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I knew I had time.
Uh, no, Jace, thank you for 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Just join the stream and watch the Venom twerking.
Of course, I'll start following you.
But all else, fellas.
Venom will at least be there for me.
No matter what happens, he'll be there for me.
Oh.
I'm just relaxed now.
You know what's crazy?
For those who didn't know, they added the Funko Pop shop.
What the fuck is...
What the fuck is going on here?
Is this the meeting of fucking, oh my god.
It's a wedding with...
Is this the bachelor party I was invited?
Is this a bachelorette party?
Who ordered the entertainment?
It's the bachelorette party!
Let's go!
Yeah!
I heard it's someone's special day tomorrow!
Happy birthday, Mr. President.
Oh, don't worry.
The bride-to-be will get a special discount.
God, I love...
I love parties.
Nice.
Oh my god, we're all joining here.
What the fuck is this guy?
Why is he doing here?
He's just reading a book.
Who invited this guy?
I like how this person has not moved.
All the other, all the other girls moved away.
But I envy Ashbourne was like, this is it.
My wedding, my party.
Everyone else like, story time.
Story, story time with the thing.
the other one's like i paid for this i paid for this
entertainment i'm getting it we yeah we know who ordered the
cake all right oh it's e honda what what is he doing here
what is he doing here what is e honda doing here oh my gosh
the first is i have a penny have why do we have a penny they
have a penny penny what else do you play you can ban it if
you want appreciate you oh no guys what the doing it okay
maybe we should okay maybe we shouldn't have left you we've
been gambit okay that was my bad we've been in this that was
that's my bad I I fucked up I took a gambit I took a gambit
and silly me today was obviously not my day uh The entire
games have been telling me today is not your day, Doki.
You're not going to have good games, so just take what you
can get.
But silly me, I...
Pick your hero.
Okay.
The grass is always greener.
It really is.
It really is always greener on the other side.
Oh,
that's funny.
That's funny.
Triple dive.
I like it.
Oh, my God.
What is this?
The grass is never...
You're right.
All my grass is dead.
It's just dead.
We didn't ask to be heroes.
But we always finish the party set.
Do I go RFS or BP?
Get ready.
Fucking what the bro, I feel like iron fist.
Oh yeah, iron fist.
Yeah.
Like iron fist is better peels if needed.
No, they've...
Grass is like burnt.
Nothing is...
It's like...
You know, like when a nuclear bomb drops on a field and then
like grass never grows back there again?
That's what my grass looks like right now.
Maybe I should play on full screen.
Maybe?
Maybe.
You know what?
I'm fucking...
Fuck it.
Maybe.
Maybe that's all I need Full screen Maybe Maybe something
will happen Maybe something will change You know I'm like
I'm coping But like I'm just thinking Like Maybe Maybe Maybe
I just need to cope A little bit Here Just maybe Oh and they
have a Spider-Man too That Yeah That's fine.
Nice.
I need to start.
You know, I'll take this.
You know, I'll take...
Oh, I used up my pull.
Let's hope nobody gets grabbed.
No touchy, no touchy.
I don't have pull, no touchy.
Maybe they'll be nice.
No touchy, guys.
Yeah.
Oh my god, they touched me, they touched me.
Oh my...
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's fine.
There is a...
Oh!
Oh my...
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm alive!
Oh my, oh my, please, please, I can't move, I can't, I
actually can't move, I won't disappear so easily, okay, I'm
not, I'm going back to borderless, I, I can't move, we're
gonna have both the portals, but, I, I, I, I, they was, they
just kept grabbing me.
Oh nice, let's go.
Next off the map, fuck it.
Ready on me, try on me.
Don't mess with the amazing city!
We have to live, we have to live.
Oh my god, I'm dead, goodbye.
Yay!
You walked this hello.
Oh, no longer, yeah.
No longer, yay.
I do not feel very yay.
We die.
One of us will die.
Let's watch.
Hey, let's go.
That's...
Let's go.
That's what...
You can tell why...
Okay, I knew I was going to be the one that they were going
to aim for.
That's why I didn't stand.
Do you guys notice how I didn't stand near my team?
That stood?
Because everyone else was super bunched up.
Did you notice how I actually, I stood away from my team?
Because I knew that it was going to be me.
I had a feeling.
Oh my god.
You think the Spider-Man is over?
right now like I took one I didn't have shield I already
used it when I was getting fucking touched by a spider-man
and Angela like I don't know if you guys saw that but but I
was not okay bro bro bro bro the fight is still bro there's
No, it's not what's...
Oh, oh.
He's like, yay.
Wait, did you see him?
He was spamming the fucking happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
Our fucking Emma kept spamming the happy birthday while the
guy, the mag just...
The mag was just touching her.
It feels good to step outside my bubble every now.
You know what?
See, it's not that bad.
Grass is...
See, it's not that bad, guys.
He's not that bad.
This map Mag can play the game a little bit, Spidey.
It's okay though.
I jinxed us, we're gonna lose now.
Because I was like, see you guys, not that bad.
Now we're gonna lose.
I jinxed us, I'm so fucked up.
Why did I say that?
Why?
I should have just been humble.
Why wasn't I just humble?
I just had to say something.
I did.
Oh, it's Beehive.
and five four three two one the curse has been activated we
have skill two accounts what like is one is one just caught
behind so did you just switch your account like a little bit
ago i got like five of them oh okay oh the spider-man i see
him i only got one
yeah yeah yeah hey at least yeah all right I'm diving like
we had to do it we all right that's that's fine I I knew
I...
I think they were getting Spider-Man.
Yeah, we were.
I won't disappear so easily.
Well...
If I didn't know that, we would have died.
But we still died it anyway.
Why do you remember it?
Hey guys, can we like...
Kill the spider?
Okay, no, he's dead.
Yeah, we ain't saving Spider-Man.
Guys, I jinxed it, guys.
I jinxed it.
I jinxed it, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, T.
Team, I'm sorry.
There we go.
Okay, we definitely didn't need all of that.
Oh, but he still died.
Where's the thing?
Deja Vu, except reverse of what happened last.
Alright.
Yeah, this one's on me.
No, I agree.
He doesn't hurt a fool.
Oh my god, I almost I almost saved them, but I fucked up.
I think above.
Big more thing.
What are you doing?
That's a good question.
I'll pass you up.
I was a bit overrode.
I'm already behind.
Oh my god.
You're trying to stall.
Okay, it's okay.
Oh my god.
It was not okay.
Guys, it was not okay.
So, yeah, Spider-Man's stalling.
Guys, it was my fault.
I jinxed it.
I should have been humbled.
Guys, I should have been high.
I don't know why.
Why couldn't I have been humbled?
Oh, I don't think I could have saved you.
I don't.
Guys, I don't think.
i could have saved it oh my god oh my god i'm trying i'm
trying
there i got him away no bad touch no bad touch oh hey um
would he be okay because oh
oh guys he was not okay he was not okay guys My bad, I
jinxed it.
I will admit, that was on me.
I will admit, I fucked that up.
I should have said anything.
I shouldn't have said anything, guys.
I should have just let it happen.
They probably have both of them.
before you attack yeah but just so did we using this all
right i'm gonna use mine you want to rock it with mine yeah
i got you all right i might switch to angela afterwards
yeah go on go on caught me having fun and it's like no no no
no no no no no no No, it don't see you.
You're not here to have fun.
I just think, like, legitimately think just unlucky teams
today.
Like, I literally lost the 50-50 90% of the time.
The top.
There's quite a little.
Cheat.
At least, I guess we're not going to top, guys.
I hope that...
Oh.
Alright.
That is?
Okay, we're fine.
I missed the...
That is okay.
Because I think it's okay.
I think it's fine.
There we go.
Yay, I didn't have to up too.
Okay, most likely they're gonna invis up my...
I mean, they're gonna Jeff up my invis up.
Knowing them.
Oh, I have to like...
I'm so scared I'm just gonna use this
Oh, I pushed that too late I'm so sorry I am so sorry, bro
That's me That's actually on me I I thought you lived To be
To be fair To I legit thought he was gonna I thought Oh my
god, no, no!
Oh, but fuck you!
Okay, my hero.
My hero.
I told you, I told you.
I could free the fucking future.
I knew he was gonna do that.
Here, I'm using the board.
No.
Oh my god, I...
Who did?
That's a bad individual.
Will we be okay?
We will be.
See, guys, saying humble works.
Give me shield.
I saved your life.
Oh, my God.
I did not realize.
I was not expecting the platform.
Okay, where's the Agile?
Oh.
No, no, no.
Rocket.
Oh, fuck up.
Stop.
Not the amazing spider.
event it's okay it's okay we got overtime
okay we do have
there we go there he goes look like that oh my god it's bad
we got the we got the we got the tour not the spider-man
though our spider-man lost the 1v1 they have no shields
isn't oh yeah i i saw the hella and i was like no We don't
have Starlight.
Rig Z.
He's like, oh.
Oh.
It's just non-stop.
It doesn't stop.
They don't support us.
and stop guys why didn't it stop okay okay oh my god come on
please you just go rocket just go just go just go Just go be
a hero.
We use all six of us all five of us.
Let's go
Guys, I think using all Okay, I will say I'll fight for my
family We'll say using all five of us was not a good idea.
It was not a good idea.
I will say that I think we fucked up.
I will say that we fucked that up.
Oh, that is absolutely a bad.
I'm blocking
heroes.
I'm blocking heroes.
Okay.
Okay, but who's gonna...
Who's gonna save one support?
Who's gonna save you though?
If it's one.
Rocket's still here.
Rocket won't...
Oh my...
Okay.
It's okay.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I've always believed.
We did it.
Guys, I've always believed in myself.
I don't know how it's needed.
No, I don't need it at all.
We fucking did it.
I don't know how.
But we did it.
I honestly don't know how this happened.
But, but we did it.
Believe in the humbleness.
Oh, 20.
At least I get 20.
At least we take this.
We actually take this.
I'm so humble.
So humble.
Only the humble and graceful victory.
I think that's what I need to do.
I think I just, that's all I need to do.
I just, I just gotta start being more humble.
Oh yeah, and then I need to do it not, it shouldn't be a
full screen.
Full screen was not, full screen is not.
it oh i'm going back to window i was not feeling the full
screen
the most humble streamer out there oh man thank you for
twitch prime thank you thank you uh shadow thank you for
gifting a tier one sub to player thank you thank you
show venom's butt please what's in it for me huh i usually
do it for free but now that I know how desperate you want
it.
Oh, what will you give in exchange?
Oh, it's because, like, my main monitor is 500 hertz.
Like, in the past, I don't have to.
You should just do full screen.
Because when you tap out, if all your monitors are the same
hertz and you tap out, it won't...
Or if all your monitors aren't the same hertz and you tap
out, it, like, does a whole...
It does a flicker.
because it has to go back to its original hertz.
So I've been doing, I have to do borderless because it's
very annoying when I'm tabbing out.
Yeah.
Because my three monitors aren't like the same hertz.
What do you mean?
Oh, I have a partnership with MSI.
And they gave me, if you do exclamation point MSI, they gave
me a free monitor because I'm sponsored by them.
Yay, so check it out.
It's actually really cool.
I got the 500 hertz monitor and I got top 500, like in two
days.
Was it exclamation point MSI?
Sorry, it's not MSI.
I don't remember what the command is.
I don't remember it.
Let me check.
I think that's on my YouTube.
I think that's the command.
Is it?
Oh, yeah.
My mod didn't put in the MSI command for...
For...
Yeah, for Twitch.
I only have it on... I only have it on YouTube.
I was like, I was like, MSI, and then...
Oh, is this Jitward?
Oh my god.
And then we have Storm, one trick, too.
That has to be Jitward.
He's the...
Daredevil player.
Man in Ganymede?
Bro, are you putting me back on it?
Bro, I'm...
I can't do this again.
I can't.
God's strong enough.
Don't put me on it.
Please, I can't do this again.
I don't know if I'm strong enough.
Oh, no.
Okay, I can do this.
I can't, but I can do this.
Yeah.
Yay!
Thank you, mine.
All right, we have our MSI.
Yeah, that's my sponsor.
I'm not the type who fades quietly.
I'm just trying to.
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking tired.
Someone.
Who looked at my stream.
Oh, my God.
And my team get...
Bro, okay, how much...
How many more handicaps do they want to give us?
I don't understand.
They already banned both my one-tricks players.
They...
Do they really...
Are they that desperate?
Hey, they took both of them.
They fucking took them back and bat and, like, smashed their
knees.
Like, I just...
Guys, come on.
Three seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Come on, guys.
Did you really have to take both my one-tricks?
Like, come on.
Let one of them play.
or one trick.
Like, it's storm.
Like, at least let the storm play your one trick.
Yeah, the steel pipe to the shins.
At least we're doing trip.
Trip is nice.
Okay, we know our Spider-Man is better than...
Oh, okay.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need to make sure my Spider-Man is alive Because T is
worrying Oh, they have back off He started walking up to me
and I got scared I have to be sure
Oh my Oh, okay Okay, I take those
Um, I don't know how the fuck I got kill there but i take
this wait is what the fuck i want to get this strange come
on oh oh oh oh oh i keep forgetting there was a hawk guy i
forgot he is guys guys guys guys there is a hawk guy we
don't want to i'm not looking at him okay that's on you like
you you do that fucking risk
Okay.
It's okay.
I did it.
Stay in this corner, Jeff.
We will live.
He can't get us.
We're in the same place now.
Time for corner, Jill.
All right.
I don't know how we did it.
Okay, I don't know why I just stood there.
I just...
I don't know.
Guys, I'm going through a lot.
Oh, no, not my shield.
My Jeff should be 5?
Oh, please.
Please, our mantis does have a...
Our mantis does have a...
Oh, good luck.
Oh.
where's our jeff oh there he is i'm not gonna look emma emma
oh my god don't okay that's fine my hero okay our phoenix is
dead but okay our emma is dead but hey i'm alive oh wait no
our our mantis is dead but hey i'm alive
Okay.
I'm alive.
And isn't that all that matters?
Oh my god, I don't think I can.
Okay.
I am gonna touch it.
I had made an attempt to touch it.
Okay.
Now they're on triple support.
but they're they're on the slightly better they're on the
slightly better comp do you know why because they have
double tanks so um because when you're running triple
support you need to have two tanks so they may or may not be
on the slightly better comp just maybe just maybe i'm not
sure yet i need more data be sure holy fuck holy fuck i
really don't want to peek this pocket oh my okay okay oh my
god i'm just gonna stay here i'm just gonna there we go
there we go oh we used two olds though but that's fine
holy okay that's okay that's okay we used to support us but
i believe in our mantis and building all the alts possible.
It's winnabur.
We might have used all, both very important supporters.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna get log, aren't I?
That's okay.
I'll make my own shield.
Can't fucking log me when I have my own shield.
Oh, and they have a Groot now.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's... Oh, okay.
Alright, alright.
We don't need support.
I leave That's fine I am alive You know In a sense And then
there is a group running at us Oh This is our The Top Oh
Okay the very unfortunate Part Oh hey that's good for our
mag he's getting a house being built on him right now and um
i'm sorry mag we really did try and save you like there yeah
mag i'm mac you don't understand they built an entire house
like a supports do not have in the okay guys
i'm too scared to actually go in here.
So, oh, and then we didn't kill anything.
Oh,
holy shit.
Hey, guys.
Oh.
What?
Why me?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that slam dunk on me?
Okay, we got save okay there's nothing to do for that okay
it's fine it's fine
watch this res three raises catch oh my god we're not
catching that okay we have so many raises now like no what
the what happened
one oh my god yeah no they played fortnight on him that guy
was not living i literally saw them build an entire fucking
house around him you'll need a top-notch team to win i am
surprised that he survived for that long
all right all right that that was rough i guys it's crazy
that invisible in invisibition so That's right.
Invisibition is so hard now.
Like, so as in, like, I feel like I'd do so much.
I'd have to do so much.
Like, guys, remember how fucking fun and calm and easy Gab
it is compared to all the stuff I have to do as Invisib
woman?
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Oh, my God.
I swear.
You can't say it.
It's okay, I'm a woman too, so I give myself a pass.
Gambit is actually like on a five-star vacation.
Yeah, that's true.
Yes.
All right, it's fine.
We don't have a Loki.
Like what the fuck is he gonna do with Moon Knight?
Oh wait.
Oh, I forgot the combo.
Okay, I realized that...
That maimed...
Alright, I'll pull him back.
I'll push the card a little bit.
Like, we have two other supports that...
That's enough healing for them.
Oh, wait, they don't have a group.
Why the fuck did they went Moon Knight?
They don't even have a group for this.
Oh, okay.
Shit worried.
that's awkward that is awkward it's okay we have
oh smoothie oh
wait actually i need to push them away do not touch them god
i'm so confused like how did they how are they getting like
fucked up right now oh my god okay it's fine it is not fine
anymore it is fine it is not fine oh don't worry i don't use
anything okay there we go i get away from that again as well
Okay, that's five.
Okay.
Okay, I don't understand.
I knew I was gonna...
Yeah, I...
Yeah, no, that felt very obvious.
But, like, somehow...
Oh, my God.
Somehow they die?
Okay.
That's not okay.
Like, I knew it was gonna happen, but what the?
Guys, I'm not very hopeful anymore.
Guys.
We have one.
Technically one.
My love, guys.
Guys.
I'm pushing him away, so Oh my god, I have to use my shield
to save it Oh my god, did I save him?
Alright, we can maybe...
Okay, this is last fight now We don't want it to be, but
like, I don't...
I don't think we can do anything about it I'm gonna use
my...
Is everything okay?
Oh my god, I...
Oh, okay, I don't think that was what we needed.
I knew it.
I knew it was gonna happen again.
I...
guys
please please we just had to kill him
hey guys why is there three people still alive up there okay
all right the hard part this is this is gonna be rough now
this is this is gonna be very rough I feel better already
It's okay.
It's oh, no, never mind.
I was gonna say it's okay.
Jibber can pull and then he got fucking kicked out.
Never mind I don't know why I believed so much for some
reason I had so much faith
Oh, come on he was so low come on
Guys Guys, please I'm so scared of him
oh my god jitward please jitward you're 18 18 bro bro please
please don't do this to me
okay i'm giving you a shield because i i have a i'm having
trouble believing in you
There we go.
Please.
Oh, shit.
We're...
Oh, no!
I did...
This fucking hot guy!
Oh.
This is so... Oh my god.
Okay, it's okay.
He res.
Okay, that is scary.
It's okay.
He has, we have a secret weapon.
Do you know what it is?
It wasn't that.
But I was going to say the Spider-Man.
We had, but I guess it was me.
It was me.
It was me in the end.
Let's go.
oh my god oh
my god that was very rough that was very rough nice okay
that's good that's that's a lot better i'm hydrating a lot
so i'm gonna go pee again i'll be right back guys
which hero do you think you want to be today
yeah i'm back and we got bareback obama and we got i forgot
to avoid i forgot to avoid
after the struggle town that i had i forgot to avoid
why didn't i do it why did it was right there
there.
I got this.
I am strong.
Oh.
It's Jitward's on the enemy team, isn't he?
I don't even know we have the better Daredevil.
I don't even know.
He's on the enemy team, isn't he?
I will say Jitward is the better daredevil i don't know who
this this daredevil is on my team but i know for a fact that
he is i i don't know maybe this daredevil is going to
surprise me but i am going to get harassed very hard in the
backlight and i don't know how to feel i know that i don't
know i might not be feeling very good
it's okay it's okay i i should have just banned daredevil i
should have been like can you i should have been like do you
think you can diff word on daredevil yes no maybe he's him
who knows maybe he's him
gaming thank you for the hundred biddies thank you thank you
thank you hey dokey love your gameplay and content i'm able
to finally see one of your streams oh thank you for the
biddies thank you thank you you've been enjoying the stream
so far oh my god it's not looking so awful don't worry i got
you oh oh but who's got us who's the oh my god and and the
hawk guy okay guys I okay we're okay who let all right I'm I
need to know who is this daredevil on my team that legend
would play daredevil
Show yourself right now.
Oh my God, he's coming.
Oh my God, I can't even pull you so fast.
I can't even pull.
He's so fast.
Oh my God.
What's going on?
Because I don't know.
Oh my god, what the fuck is going?
Okay, can you also do the let the double let the You know
let the oh, okay, all right.
What's your name?
Okay.
Yeah, Eric Matt.
Okay Yeah, no he missed yeah, no he missed Yeah, no, okay
the system.
I just wanted us to be alive.
Yeah, no.
We let Eric money.
Eric money.
Oh my god.
And we didn't.
And we didn't kill him.
And yeah, we let the wrong.
Yeah, no, no.
Eric manic money was not.
Yeah.
Guys, I don't think he was him.
I think We should have, I should have just banned Daredevil.
I should not have.
I was like, is this, I forgot.
I should have just, yep.
Yeah, you would love to get healed right now, don't you?
Maybe actually get kills.
Then maybe you can...
The fact that this Daredevil is willing to 1v1 you because
he is that confident.
My God.
That is...
That is just sad.
That is absolutely sad.
That I'm not peaking that.
Like, I don't care.
Okay, that was cool.
Like, that was pretty cool.
I will.
I'm dead.
At least.
That was pretty cool!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go again.
Guys, don't worry.
He was- Eric was just warming up.
It's okay.
He was just- clearly, right?
He was just warming up, guys.
I had to do that.
Everyone was so- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh my My god Hey guys, you know Okay The mistake was clearly
letting Eric play Daredevil It was, yeah No, that was the
mistake Yeah Time to switch things up Including which side
Yeah, no, yeah I had a feeling I was like I was like I don't
think I don't think this dare this non-lord daredevil was
gonna win and his name was Eric oh oh oh Eric oh oh now you
realize that that may be that may be the other daredevil was
a better daredevil you okay okay that's okay if only you
were if only
And he's better Yeah, I'm Yeah, yeah Yeah, I should have
fucking bad I should have bad Daredevil I should have done
it I should have done it Why did I let him Hiding from sight
is a simple task For the god of mischief It's getting you to
stop talking about yourself That's the real trick
The battle starts in five Four Okay, if you know Jitware is
like queuing at this hour like at that point you should know
it would be nice to have if we had a Bucky earlier you know
all right let's see if we live because I do not um I don't
have any reason we don't have lamps and oh and then they
pushed It's so free...
Alright.
I was gonna say, he broke all the supports resources there.
Like, every single resource, God.
Just like that.
It's crazy.
Oh my god.
Alright, that's cool.
That's cool.
I'm a little scared, but that's cool.
Oh, I'm not gonna peek them.
It's okay, we have our little corner.
We have our little corner.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
We no longer have...
We...
Oh, my God.
We no longer have our little corner.
We...
Oh, and we have it.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
so oh hey bucky why didn't you body block for our strange um
okay eric all right okay eric did not body block for our
strange and he just let him do that okay
stood behind standing by I and our strangers knowing that no
it's time to off definitely avoid Eric I am you know never
again Eric I will never trust in Eric again I will I will
never why can't you have 18 oh cause he gotta play because
he gotta play Daredevil alright I'm never letting this Eric
come near me again
what is he wait what do you say give me gonna take one game
break okay all right it's back to back to hell back to solo
queue hell
all right here you go
my laws of guan guan i'm in quick play
I just realized like wow I got a game pretty fast I'm in
quick play I was gonna be like whoa my game was so fast
maybe this game isn't dead it was quick play
that's crazy I was lied to back to town square back to back
to where i started my role play are maybe i can recruit
people this time hello everyone oh my god there's so many
people hello hello everyone i'm here to role play that was a
game You know what?
I definitely lost more than I won.
Yeah, 100%.
Wait, this is an exclusive party.
This is not...
Wait a minute.
I want to be part of the exclusive party.
Wait, can I come?
Can I join?
I want to be part of this VIP only.
That's not fair.
Can I be part of this?
I'm very important too!
Look up.
Who's up there?
What the fuck?
How the fuck did he get up there?
Let me be part of this party.
I swear to God.
I want Emma to crush my skull like a watermelon bitch.
Jesus Christ, bro.
What?
Question mark?
Oh, I can't even, I want to know, like, what rank are you to
say this, these things?
Do Jeff the Sky Shark?
I'm so sad.
I'm not important enough to be part of this party.
I don't understand.
Why can't I be part of this party?
I deserve to be included.
I demand to be included!
He said...
speaks the truth.
Come on, guys.
Come on, Jeffs.
Surely one of you guys.
Surely one of you guys are close to all.
I want to be part.
I want to be part of this exclusive club.
Well, I've been streaming.
Oh, my God.
I've not slept yet, guys.
I do not have a problem.
Streamer spotted who.
Can't be me, because I'm out of here.
Alright.
Oh, guys, just Assyrian Prince.
I'm going to lose so much.
I am going to lose so much, you know.
Why the fuck does the other team have an MRC winner?
Oh, God.
Okay, alohi.
Guys, I can't sleep though.
I'm not dying.
All I need, all I need is my vivables.
It's not sad.
Only for today.
Like I said, I feel like, I honestly feel like Rink is so
much more toxic now.
Compared to...
I think rank is actually like...
It's not like fun toxic anymore.
It's actually mean.
People are sort of really mean now.
I think people got a lot worse in rank.
What the fuck?
So I can only do this in like small doses.
Unless someone else yells at me and then I'll go live.
That's the only thing I...
Unless I get yelled at, then I'll go...
Then I'll go live.
Because I'm not gonna get yelled at for free.
I cannot.
Please.
I don't know.
When I say I cannot, I cannot.
I'm not batting hell anymore with zero DPS players is a
choice.
Why do we plan to take takes when we all be had our take
players, guys?
I am accused of loving...
Broken bond.
Then you look at the children biddies.
Thank you.
It wasn't today supposed to be a rest day.
Yes, but then I got yelled at by two pro players.
And then I got sad.
And then so then I was like, I'm going to stream because
they yelled at me.
Literally the best thing player in the world.
At least my dragons there are going to be my emotional
support.
animals like so that's why i'm not i'm playing thing into
literally any pro you can think of that i go through who are
you what's your name who are you what's your name i'm gonna
i'm gonna wait and see if they're on poke or not i'll just
who are you like i can play thing into like honey hawkeye
but my teammates get tilted when i do yeah because it's dumb
ass matchup bro bro are you with a gm player are you the gm
player i need a dope what do you what do you mean i usually
drop 50.
all right what the are you talking about oh i have to swap
up
I have to I need reload Please
Oh my god I have to swap off though I have to swap off Oh my
god Alright we're going Mantis I'm not playing Loki Into
Bucky Oh that sucks Alright That sucks
I don't damage All right It's fine It's not It's fine I love
coping It's the only way I can Progress through rivals
Oh okay look Yeah I've been never Oh okay that's Oh okay
okay okay Um okay Fucking all right okay you're living
you're live right you're live hey guys hey please please
please oh my god thank you thank you oh my god thank you i
had to stand in front of the gambit it was the only way It
was truly the only way.
Maybe I can Kobe that.
The fact that I had to stand in front of my gamut to get
healed was a little concerning, but that's the case.
Sometimes...
Oh, I would have damage boosted him if I...
Oh, he's fucking gone.
He is so... He's alive.
He's alive.
I've always believed.
I'm slowly backing up.
Because I am slowly not feeling very good about this.
Alright, nice.
And now I leave.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh, wait, we got...
Oh my gosh.
Avery, I think?
Yeah.
That's Avery.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I need you to know I saved your life.
You're fucking old.
You're welcome I know that's Avery smurf The sen Because
like he's actually he used to be in sentinels All right,
it's fine.
See I have nothing for hello.
Haha, I have this though It'll be fine I have All right.
All right.
Oh, oops.
Sorry, that was my bad.
That was my bad.
I got scared.
You know?
Now we definitely don't have anything.
That was my bad.
That was actually my bad.
I just got very scared.
I definitely, I definitely maybe should not have loaded
that.
I'm sorry.
I got very scared.
Alright.
Reset.
Unless...
No, that's Avery.
Because Avery used to be a Fortnite player and then and then
and then he just makes they don't have anything.
And then he fucking named alt accounts after Fortnite
players.
I didn't say for him, but I think I learned Jeff would have
died.
If I didn't know.
If I did.
Oh When you when you ult a three I have to pop or fuck you.
It's gonna kill you All right, here we go.
Hey guys, someone's asleep
That's fine, right?
How please It's fine nice
Nice I am... You're alive?
Wait, we can stagger... Oh, we hear a staggered air.
Wait.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, he's the last one.
That's okay.
We're doing it.
It swallows Jeff.
Oh my god.
See?
See, this Jeff knows how to play the game.
Whoops.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Be humble, Doki.
Be humble.
Don't be too overconfident.
Anything can happen.
Yeah, that Jeff knows how to swallow.
I'm pretty sure I missed my Maggle on the C&D, but I got the
kill set.
30 seconds before you attack.
Oh, it's the splash damage.
It's the fucking splash damage.
Yeah, I was watching her.
She walked left after you threw it to the right.
So I think she, like, walked right into it.
That was a long time ago.
No, Jeff swallows N-spit.
Do you not see the bubbles?
all that power yeah it's also super weird like i didn't
realize or i don't mag all often in gambit or whatever it's
like or maybe i got he's so versatile i know my movement is
like really fast no i was an old this isn't exactly the
homecoming i was hoping for yeah gambit gives a huge speed
boost all right here you go yeah like teleported around okay
he has this is it this is your time to shine you literally
have all for this oh my Okay, it's fine.
They're one.
Oh my God, he blew in the aqua.
Damage, go up.
That's right.
Gambit never what?
Yeah, we did it.
All right.
Oh, no, he's fucking dead.
Bro, I can't get over there, bro.
Oh, he's alive.
I fucking knew it.
I knew he was gonna be alive.
Always believe in him.
Never doubted.
Jesus Christ, okay.
I don't know what the fuck is going on right now.
He definitely has, uh...
Oh, my God.
I'm alive.
Yeah, I'll give you damage boost.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to scratch my nose.
Oh Oh, he was so low.
He's so low Like we can heal that right?
Yeah He's that guy is still there Oh my god.
Oh my god.
That's stupid fucking okay.
It's fine.
He definitely has grew up.
There it is Okay He doesn't see me, right?
He doesn't
Oh, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He definitely didn't see me.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
I thought he was going to hit him.
I, I, okay, I don't know if you guys saw this, but like, I
waited.
I waited for him to...
Like, I waited for him to shoot the name more, and he didn't
shoot him.
understand
it's like you're gonna shoot him right we like literally
stared at him I was like yeah you're gonna do it right and
he didn't do it I was so confused bro you gotta keep telling
me when you're doing that shit wait who fucking touched
oh nice it's fine Yay!
Oh, they had someone left.
Poor hell.
That would fit...
Yeah, no.
Apparently our team was definitely broken.
We take those.
Yay!
That's great.
Thank God.
Thank God we actually have...
We actually had the players for once in our lives.
Okay.
That's crazy.
I didn't know how that felt until now.
I didn't know how that felt like having real players.
Will she get back to Celestia 2?
The better question is, will she be ranked in Dramaster?
That's the better question.
Will I survive?
Oh, at least Venom's here to turn me up.
Yeah!
But um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but um, but
um, but um, but um, but is Choppa climbing?
He asked me to play like a while ago.
Oh, he got back.
Good for him.
But I was already in a duo, so I was like, sorry, Choppa.
Why are you not live?
Because I want to feel a pain.
Oh, okay.
I'll be late.
All right.
No problem.
Yeah.
He has a job.
Like regular people.
Not like me.
Well, this is my job.
It's not like I do have a job, guys.
This is my job.
Technically.
But like.
But like I got I'm just playing for the fun of it.
I'm not jobless This is my job You guys want to support me
via other means You can do exclamation point Merch And then
you can buy some of my merch And it does support me too And
you can have you know You can have actual stuff related to
me Sorry my brain is so fried right now.
All I could do is just think, breathe, and play rivals.
Rat, thank you for Twitch pride.
Thank you.
What?
Let me scroll through.
Let me, I bookmarked some stuff.
I knew that if I had anything, I would want, oh yeah.
Do you guys know that uh, oh my gosh, what is this?
Oh, guys, do you guys know about the Kabuto shit?
That shit is crazy.
Bruh.
the kabuto market uh we're like uh okay so you know how
there's a pokemon card market um we're like you know
scalpers and stuff like that and we're like people are
scalping pokemon cards and like selling like buying selling
pokemon cards so there's one guy who's fucking obsessed with
this one pokemon called kabuto and the thing about it is
that i swear to god is fantastic uh fantastic is a fantastic
player i swear to fucking god anyway so the whole premise is
that he's the kabuto guy and his entire okay sorry i just
have to figure out like what the fuck is is my team i just
had to i have to process this okay okay is my team decent or
not um and he only collects first edition kabuto cards so
originally apparently the card was originally like less than
one dollar and through his efforts because his whole mission
is that you are not okay i swear to god if you guys do not
ban daredevil next i swear to fucking god like oh thank god
okay um sorry i i'm just getting distracted by my team um
and he raised sit to like because he's been trying to buy
every single fucking kibuto um he raised the market value
for the card to i think like 30 plus dollars per card and
now scalpers are hoarding kibuto cards because they think
it's like the stock market where they're like oh yeah he's
like he's like upping the price value of them so like we
should just we should hoard these cards so like it'll get
higher and yeah but then scalpers are making it not fun by
hoarding the cards now so that's not the best yeah because
they're like oh the card value yeah but yeah i know but he's
literally the only buyer yeah he
created all the demand so so scalpers are also like it's
like stock market it's like your very own babies for stock
market where they're buying the kubuto cards too like
scalpers are also buying the kubuto cards and artificially
uh artificially like uh increasing the value of it even
though like he's he's literally the only customer he's the
only customer for the kubuto cards none of your business
when you enter my realm i will No, not everything.
And just put it here.
There's no way to know, right?
It's right here.
I have to play Rocket because they ban Gambit and I don't
know what else to play.
And if they play Phoenix, I go, I don't fucking know.
I guess fuck me, I guess.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know what to do if they go Phoenix, okay?
We'll figure it out as we go.
Alright.
go along like surely surely I can figure this out oh my god
oh my god I turn around for one second I'm that is awkward
that is so awkward I I turn around for look I can't kill you
all the time bro like I'm sorry oh my god and they have
widow holy shit okay this is like what the fuck okay i'm
trying to make sure our star lord gets healed also but now
i'm like i'm not sure anymore like guys i am not sure about
my heels i am
okay this is awkward Oh, that sucks.
He just didn't have the shield.
Hey, guys.
We have Invisal, so, like, maybe touch...
No?
Okay, that's cool.
Okay.
Okay, that's...
That's cool.
That's...
I'm gonna go, Loki.
Stop backing up.
Hey, guys.
Hey, hey guys.
Hey guys.
Stop backing up.
Do you think, um, you think they knows I'm up here?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Mag, mag, mag, mag.
Mag, mag, what's mag?
Mag?
So that was six of us.
So that was indeed six of us.
Hey, so, like, am I helping?
Hey, guys, remember the whole stop backing up?
I don't think we're...
We're not...
Oh, we're...
Okay.
I mean, to be fair, we have the back...
Okay, to be fair, we have the backup here, though.
Like, that's...
There's nothing else we can do.
Please die near my...
Please die near my res.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, god damn it.
I tried.
I really did.
I did.
I really did try.
I tried a body block that.
Hey, stop backing up.
Stop, stop.
Wait, where did it?
Oh, there's my up.
There you go.
I was gonna say, where is my up?
go Loki.
Oh, we are very bad with all.
We are very, very bad with all.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um.
He doesn't know.
Okay, I didn't realize he was gonna touch, but it's okay.
It's okay.
Our mag got respawned All right, it's Loki time Wait, I
could still get another respawn in
Oh my god, I couldn't get another respawn in I could
Okay, okay, no, I don't think this I I think it's a team
issue question mark.
It's okay Okay, it's not okay anymore.
I'm gonna go low-key now.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you need to shoot this venom, dude.
Yo, I think I've been trying to.
Oh, twin.
When I was on DPS, I was the only one shooting that bitch.
You can ask both for some more.
I don't know if you are now.
Oh, yeah.
We shoot the venom when I just got my head blown off.
You mean, bro.
Just play backline.
Just bagged on.
I have many faces.
Mag, I...
Okay, that...
If we get a Jeff, we need to rush these people.
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck it.
He wants a...
Let's go.
Yeah, we just need to start rushing up, though.
Let's see.
He asked for a Jeff.
I...
Good luck, everyone.
Good luck.
I think things are working.
I think.
Oh my god, hey guys.
I don't know when to all...
Oh my god, I'm eating business stuff.
And oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know when all this stuff.
I'm just gonna save this until I know.
Until I know what to do.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm just eating business stuff.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god, look at that, nice.
I still don't know when up.
Oh, when I'm hungry.
That's a good idea yet.
Oh my god.
Hulk was very mad.
Okay, we'll do Invis first and then...
Oh.
2Gs.
Okay, maybe?
Oh Oh my god Okay, yeah, okay The spider-man the spider-man
the spider-man picked up the mantis the moment.
Okay, I That was not on me the spider-man actually Bro, how
the fuck
was I did so much
Oh my god he missed He missed He missed Oh he's not me
Okay Wait when the fuck did I In this?
I don't even remember that Oh my god I'm trying to reload
I'm trying to reload Oh I'm trying my best.
Oh, my.
Kind of done.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This is it.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
I fucked up.
He's won.
Yay.
It's okay.
I fucked up.
But we still did it.
I swore I'm getting rage baited.
Like, I've been, like, one shot at five times, and then I
got mad.
It's okay.
Never punished.
This is an egregious game.
Like, I don't know why I came back to this shit.
It's okay.
I'm just doing business.
I'm just...
I tried.
That's what matters.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
All part of the plan.
Honestly, I don't know what you play, bro.
You're lucky.
I was trying to just run three tanks and run them down.
I'm not even like, oh, that has me.
That is what would happen.
Like, you should unironically just...
I don't know how to...
I don't know how to all that's, Jeff.
That is.
I'm just...
I'm feeling it.
I'm just playing off of vibes.
It's just off of vibes.
I don't know what I'm...
It's just vibes.
It is not fun.
You should hit that bubble and run after.
This is not...
Okay.
I don't know if this is enough feeling.
and just bubble i don't know i don't know this is okay just
going together like just dive them at the same time just
bully their invis bruv do i still play jeff
oh my god i forgot i have freaking forgot about the little
abilities
oh my god i just remembered i had that oh he's fuck don't
worry guys we don't know kick we don't know kick hell no
stun hey guys maybe oh it's okay it's okay it's not really
okay because um where are the other tanks all right we're
dead we're dead i'm going back three two one i'm on that
nice there you go there you go you can't die
okay so where did anyone get the license plate on the angela
like um what what wait actually who shot me yeah i can die
okay who shot me again don't worry jeff's coming in wada
wada and he wada the way wada wada and he wada the way water
water it's okay i wallow the way it's okay can he wallow the
way god i feel so slow as jeff though like i don't know when
to use my oh i'm so confused i'm gonna put that here just in
case
oh my god okay
That's my turn.
Mad is dead.
No way.
Oh my god.
Where is everyone?
Guys.
I got mag all out.
I- Oh, my team's dead.
My team's dead.
Okay.
okay i but guys i got the all out though oh my is he doing
okay oh my god okay so i got the bag all out i'm about here
unfortunately that's fine it's fine it's okay now we're down
for you okay never mind i thought i thought i don't know i
didn't think He was still looking at me.
I might have to swap.
I don't think this is it.
I'll do one more death.
I'll do one more.
And then I'm swapping.
I think it works on defense.
But like, I legitimately do not think I'm cut up for a
shark.
What up, what up, what up?
He's winning.
I can't see you from there, bro.
All right, it's okay.
All right.
Who is he on?
I'm just spraying.
I'm spraying and praying and hoping that I'm doing
everything I need to do.
I'm just spraying.
I'm doing it.
I'm fucking doing it right now.
Oh my god.
I have no idea where he just got shot.
All right here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
could we just invest let's back up this guy okay anyone
willing to help goodbye
oh my god go go go
okay okay spider-man okay spider-man you are okay okay
there's nothing else I don't know I just okay okay all right
that's fine that's fine that's fine one day I'll be okay one
more death one more death I think it's sort of working it's
sort of it's okay it's sort of working I just don't know how
I'll just save my all you know what I'll never all I'll just
never all at this point like I think we all learned
something i think i think it's just it's just bait at this
point it's it's happens it's just bait i there it is just
never honestly honestly that's the only way
i legitimately don't think i can do anything else
I don't know.
I think I wasted that, but that's fine.
I got scared.
Oh, my.
Is this winnable?
No, it's not.
It's not.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
I bait ult, so it's good, guys.
Fourth time's the charm.
I don't think they realize how many times I think I've not
been blamed yet.
I think I will be very soon.
So this is my last attempt.
This is my last attempt.
Oh my god, we don't even have.
Oh my god, okay.
You need a swap, brother.
They have four counter you did.
feeling fantastic okay oh my god oh oh my god oh my god okay
that's fine i just wanted to swap that's fine
It's fine.
I said that was my last chance.
I saved my team, though.
Guys, I need you to know.
I saved my team.
It was worth it because I did save.
Are you serious?
What the fuck shot me from all the way there?
Oh, no.
I had to push the res closer because...
Okay, okay, if he dies, if he dies, I do have a res right
here.
Okay, we don't have res, we don't have support else anymore.
So, oh my god, save our Invis.
She's our only hope.
Save our Invis.
This is just Maggie, she's fine.
Oh My god, oh my god I have a rest right here.
I have oh my god Please tell me that's in range.
Please.
Oh my god.
It is
Okay, okay Swear to God, bro shoot the raccoon shoot the
raccoon.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Oh, but never punished never punished.
I?
never punished never fucking punished I was not there's no
way never punished I know I know I got carried bro I got
plus 15 to get I know I know I I only went and jeff because
they were like go jeff and i was just like okay okay yes i
don't go so go jeff we did i'm not the best jeff player but
i guess i'll do it
a win is oh exactly exactly i did beat the system i i was
not supposed to I don't know how I did it, but I did it.
I got a P again.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
So I gotta disassociate for a sec.
What a game.
Now, I did not deserve that win, but I will gladly take it.
Because I, although I did not deserve that win, I deserved
that game.
I deserve to get carried after everything I've been through.
You guys can't say that I'm wrong.
I deserve to get carried after everything I've been through
the entire six hours.
With all the other games I have to go through.
Now, I deserve to have one game that I get to get carried.
No, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
The Jays, they even tier one sub.
Plus 15 is plus 15.
Exactly.
What is this?
It's called...
We all know what my rival is.
Why do you all question?
After release of release of skins that we get, we all know.
We all know.
We all know what this game is.
How do you all still question it?
you want to be today all right why am i getting all the
storm players band gambit or it's okay what the fuck okay
now who am i gonna banish all right is he gonna ban gambit
i'll do it hawk guy guys
um Okay, I believe in this ban.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I'll ban Gambit for him, because I don't want him to
start ending.
I really, I don't want him to start ending, so I'll do it
for him.
I'll take what I can get.
You know, I'll make him happy.
Today's his birthday.
Happy birthday.
You get this.
I don't want to risk it.
I'm scared.
he'll get angry at me
all right i'm
not judging all right i guess i go i really want to go luna
this time i deserve this game i deserve to play rocket
honestly okay maybe okay maybe i shouldn't have rocket it's
okay it's okay when the chips are down you want your heroes
as long as they don't play Phoenix we should be fine and
then he's gonna play he's gonna play Phoenix isn't he the
enemy team is gonna have a Phoenix aren't they they're gonna
they're gonna have Phoenix I could feel it
Oh yeah, cutscenes are always skippable.
Fucking course AI.
Why the fuck?
I would not want to watch that over and over again when I
play Ring.
Why is Captain America gonna get twerky when they're not
cowards?
Three, two, one!
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
I want to stop being cowards.
Oh, also because I have a good PC.
That's why you guys think they have all right watch this
All right, they're not gonna find this Oh my god, everybody
is so far away and I'm a little concerned Like All right,
it's fine.
Why is everybody playing so fucking far?
Oh my god.
I hope you're okay Oh my Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
we help each other oh okay i don't know how i don't know why
he's all okay guys guys guys my res does not go that way oh
wait it does jk because it absolutely guys there is a mag on
point and that is why we cannot cap there you go oh okay um
oh no
Okay.
I mean, okay.
That works, you know?
Nice, I don't have to use those.
I'm not fucking.
Get me out of here.
That ship is just like me, guys!
Let's go!
Oh, they run trap bullet support.
Their triple is burnt out.
always been triple support yay he's just like me thank god i
deserve
all right don't worry don't worry i got you i don't know
about our hella though i'm a little worried about our hella
oh no i need to reload all right i don't think our hella
wins this nope
It's okay!
I got the alt out!
The alt is now gone!
The alt is gone!
I repeat, the alt is now gone!
But it was out!
It was out there!
It's out!
It's gone now, but it was there!
It was there!
Is he...
Or is he...
gonna be alive?
Is he...
He'll be fine, right?
Yeah, he'll be fine.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, I'll, I'll, guys.
Spider-Man, why don't you want to, Spider-Man, you can come
back here.
Okay, so, honestly, I think, no, I gotta keep playing this.
I don't know what else I can play at this point.
Like, uh, yeah, definitely not Luna with that cop.
I guess I could technically play Loki.
but like I don't know man this is yeah this is a lot oh I
didn't even realize the mantis saw my beacon I was not
paying it oh my god and he lost he lost the bull he lost the
gotcha okay I'm climbing this so he can't see me oh Okay,
okay, I tried.
I really did.
I have to reload.
I have to reload, bro.
Save him, save him, save him.
Oh my god, it's lookup, man!
Oh my god, it's lookup, man.
It's...
It's him.
I just realized who he is.
Let's look up, Matt.
What a fucking...
Okay, sent- okay, okay, okay, mag, mag.
I know that Hawk has, so I'm, like, a little worried here.
Hey.
Mac, dude.
Like the moment.
This is real firepower.
I'm on high ground.
Wait a minute.
What is he doing there?
Wait.
He doesn't see this, right?
Okay, sentry, sentry, sentry, bro.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Don't mess with the amazing spider.
Hey guys.
Hey, are we still okay?
Are we still cooking?
I don't think we're okay anymore.
There's...
Okay, we got that out.
We got that out.
Guys, we got that.
We got two ults out.
Look at that.
There we go.
That's how we do it.
Nice.
And then are we gonna, okay, we're not gonna kill him.
That's fine.
That's okay, too.
That's okay.
We don't need to kill him
Where's she coming?
You are
Okay, I'm just gonna be over here Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Okay,
okay, okay guys, okay, okay.
I cannot.
Guys, guys, please.
All right, there you go, there you go.
There you go.
Guys, guys, we can't leave for it.
I swear to God, we can't leave for it.
Okay, it's gone, it's gone, it's gone.
All right, and now they, okay, it's not winnable anymore.
It's not winnable anymore.
It is absolutely not winnable anymore.
I just...
I did live forever.
I knew it wasn't winnable.
That is so unlucky.
I felt like I did so much there.
When the chips are down, you want your heroes a little
roguish and scruffy.
Like me.
Oh my god.
No, it was not winnable.
It was...
I was crawling everywhere.
I was literally crawling everywhere.
I don't think going Loki would help anything.
I legit don't think...
I don't think Loki would do anything.
I have to...
I'm like crawling everywhere on rockets.
The fact that I live so long just fucking flying everywhere.
Bro, I don't think bro...
We have...
Bro, I don't think you're going to get that.
Bro, this guy is a Storm Fantastic player.
He is not swapping.
Good luck.
And I think...
And they're running triple support.
Oh my god, I didn't even see that.
Who the fuck took my beacon?
I didn't even see who took it.
I don't know, I feel like, eh, what would be?
Nah, I think if I was Luna, I'd get, like, extra fucked in
general.
I think, like, they would, I would not be alive.
I feel like, I'm literally doing my best, like, trying to
stay alive here.
And trying to pocket my Invis so much, like, literally,
this.
Oh, yeah.
My god.
Hello.
Oh, goodbye.
He missed.
He...
You fucking miss.
Okay, I have to use this.
I don't think we're winning.
I got concerned about not winning this fight.
Yeah, I had to use that.
Really didn't want to.
But it felt like we were absolutely not winning that.
Guys, Sarah, you're asking a DPS to swap off DPS.
Like I think you're asking a little too much.
You want a DPS to swap off of DPS, guys.
Like, bro, who do you think you are?
Oh, my God.
I should have...
I should have went.
We had to die there.
I should have went to pocket her.
I didn't know where the fuck she went.
yeah not only are you asking a dps to swap off to the tank
you're asking a mr fantastic and a spider man to swap off dp
swap off dps that is uh
that is not that is a crazy talk right there god this mantis
is like like how is he seeing where i put my fucking
instantly too that's the worst part like instantly like i'm
just choking it for now and i don't even know he's there hey
you know like yeah that's good there you go there you go
don't mess with the amazing spider-man sorry magokit no he's
not what the oh my god hey hello everyone
oh my god i was just there
Oh, and then the Mr. Fantastic Blames our tank
Oh, that is crazy The guy that was Just look up The guy
blames our only tank Okay, I'm avoiding this guy for sure By
the way, our tank Has the most final hits Even if he missed,
our tank still had the most final hit.
Oh my god, I lost him.
Ooh.
I should...
I don't know who else to avoid.
They were all pretty bad.
The thing is, I'm fucking it.
Yeah, the tank having the most final hits, that's pretty
embarrassing.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's okay.
just be like that
are my hours do I have 898 hours I think you minus 100 hours
though from me accidentally AFKing minus 100 hours because I
have AFKed in this game no I will not clear my notifications
I will not do it this though this guy do rank he was
celestial too but um but um but um but um wait actually i
gotta check um how to check avoids uh i don't remember how
to check avoids uh i'll manage I gotta know this guy.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
God damn it.
I want to know what his...
Wait, I can check.
Wait, I can.
I can still check his rank.
I don't want to unavoid him just because...
Okay, wait.
I need to check his...
Guys, did you see what his rank was?
I need to know.
Celestial 2?
There's no way.
Why does Guan Guan favor him?
a donors i've been a good person
i've been such a good person and yet guan guan decides to
favor him and give him like the actual decent games like i
don't understand what have i done wrong how could they do
this to me i mean not avoiding the spider-man because like
The thing is a good Spider-Man is actually very scary.
So, like, I don't know if, like, every time I avoid a
Spider-Man, they, like, and we don't have a DPS that can
counter Spider-Man.
Like, the Spider-Man ends up shitting on me.
But I know, because the Spider-Man, Spider-Man is, like, hit
or miss.
When they hit, they fucking hit.
When they miss, it's 18 to 18.
It's, like, it's like 5 kills and 18 deaths.
When they hit, it's, like, 50 kills and 4 deaths.
like so I'm not risking it at a yeah they return exactly if
I avoid a spider-man what if they fucking lock it in I don't
that's the risk I'm not gonna take I'm I'm not layering this
fucking Spider-Man lock-in.
If he's got lock-in, it better be on my fucking team.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright.
Surely we don't have a fourth support player, right?
Guys, we don't have a fourth support player, right?
And we have at least one more tank, right?
Surely we don't have five support players on this team.
That would be so fucking silly If that happens Right
That would be way too silly There's no way There's no way
the world decided to give me five support players The world
cannot be that cruel
Daredevil is so hard, man their double is just so fucking
hard to play against
all right let's see okay okay i got the spider-man player
that's okay he's gonna lock it in right here that's okay
this is where he locks in guys i did get up getting the
spider-man player but it's okay this is where he locks in
guys this is it so no no no this is the game he will lock in
because like because like the odds are like there's no way
you lose every spider-man game like how are you in my e-load
you end up losing my all spider-man games in the end like
you should be out of there like you shouldn't even be able
to play with me anymore so like I believe I am the game
where he still continues on in this Elo He only loses your
spider-man game surely this is the game where he wins,
right?
Like he has to win more than lose to be in this Elo, right?
Right that's how a statistic works area got it all right
things will oh oh oh whoa that's cool wait that's pretty
cool what just happened oh my god okay okay I just used it
up but like it was worth it because our gambit is still
alive now
Okay.
Surely.
Wait, what the fuck?
Hold on, down on your left.
Oh my god.
I have to turn over me.
Because of the hella.
The hella confused me.
There's no way.
I have to reload.
Please.
Oh my.
Okay, it's fine.
it's fine it's fine look what i have i have all of this and
now i don't have all of that anymore so please live no oh my
god okay it's fine it's fine i messed up i messed up i will
admit I will admit I messed up I Will admit I fucked up
there.
I fucked up there.
I did fuck up
Oh my god, I was trying to I was trying to copy our Loki and
then I tried copy our Gavin and then I don't know how the
brute got in the way Oh, you should probably someone should
probably go a second.
I don't know how the fuck I accidentally copy the group I
don't know how that happened.
I even have double confirm and I was like that looks like a
group, right?
That looks like a group right there.
Oh my god, it really is the same guy Oh my god, he also
fucked up he also Okay, okay, okay, okay okay
I don't know if that was the low-key fucking up or like the
Groot ulting there Because that was a very fast Groot Let's
try Do we not use
There we go
Okay, I'm gonna not fuck up this copy this time I think I
think.
I'll try and grab the fellow's attention, but y'all need to
take care of.
Despite that, they don't have a DPS.
Okay.
All right, we mirrored, we mirrored.
That should be fine, right?
There we go.
All right, we mirrored.
That's fine.
Oh my god, he is.
I'm just gonna be here.
Oh my god, I don't have...
I don't have...
The only issue is I don't have...
I'm freaking so much work!
What I meant is I don't have Invan.
oh my god where is she moving my brain oh no is she cleansed
oh no retreat your powers are mine okay oh fuck
are you fucking kidding me are you oh my My god.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
This sucks.
I don't have it involved.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
The timing.
I actually got timed so hard.
I'm so sad.
I got fucking time there.
yo hello i can't believe i got time yo yo are we playing the
same game guys why did my spider-man not get a single uh
pull off the map on the best spider-man map
okay guys apparently apparently i am not apparently i am not
the i am never playing mantis in my whole life apparently i
am no it's not just jeff i could go like anybody anything
besides jeff though if you play tank it'd be good too i mean
i don't really play tank either i could play angela i could
play angela hold on they played nothing then oh okay it's
fine all right oh it's fine okay okay um how did he get here
on jeff on own jeff and Invis like when we just like saw the
start of the game how how did you get here oh so I why do I
see like guys guys I told like guys like like at this point
it's not even it's not me it's like like Guan Guan is just
deciding not give me the actual teammates needed like I
don't understand why how like I'm not these people i i don't
yeah the hella and mantis are just running the whole lobby
we need to do something about this i don't know how like how
like why can't i be on that other team why why can't i be on
the other team guy
I Guys Can we come go over because um, I don't know if you
guys know this but I alted and I am very concerned that we
did Didn't push forward With my my alt The whole team's in
dude
I'm a little concerned
Are we not gonna worry about okay.
I'm like I don't
Okay, um do I okay are we are we okay.
We're not shooting.
We're not shooting it.
Okay, that's fine That's fine.
Let's not shoot it.
That's okay Are you I broke she just grabs me
Then how am I gonna kill her all right so oh my god he did
it He fucking did it Oh my guys, you guys he did it.
I'm so guys nobody shoots her oh my god he fucking did it he
got it i'm the only one contesting her and she has amethyst
bro why can't that be me i like why can't that be me that'd
be so cool i feel like i think i should deserve that duo
only killing you there we go we save because you keep trying
to one-to-one go on the flank and shoot other people bro
yeah bro Alright, I saved the Emma.
Oh my god.
Please tell me I can...
There we go.
I can't...
Alright, I don't know if we needed that, but like...
Their team is so bad.
We can show up to how on Mantis...
Yeah.
okay okay guys guys this is possible guys this is this is
possible okay okay i am very scared but this is still
Please don't
Press shift I press shift.
I'm so sad.
I press shift.
I swear to God There we go.
Maybe Maybe he found maybe he found.
Oh my god.
I think it worked.
I think it healed.
I think it healed guys I think it healed a little bit
Goodbye, Jeff.
Why did you just stay there?
Oh, my.
Just use your old spurt.
Okay.
So, what we learned today was I think Gwangwan just really
hates me right now.
I don't know what I did wrong.
Maybe because of Elo-Terrorized way too long.
That now the game decided you've been Elo-Terrorizing for so
long.
It's your turn to get Elo-Terrorized.
All right, no, I'll avoid the Spider-Man.
No, I think it's time.
I think he has proven himself to be not one of the good
ones.
He is definitely not one of the good Spider-Man.
How?
He has a fucking okay.
Okay.
Why couldn't this be me?
I don't understand.
Oh wait, that was me.
That...
Yay.
Wait, never mind.
That one was me.
But like, why could this also be me?
okay guys i don't know i don't know about avoiding him
anymore because like he's actually been doing okay guys i'm
not avoiding him he's actually been killing it he's actually
been killing it okay i've i've decided to unavoid this guy
he's been he's been killing it it's just that was a bad
spider-man game i i'll give him one more chance he it was
just a really rough one game i believe in the next game will
be different surely surely surely all right let me
disassociate for a second i have my hands on my my hands on
my head right now i need to i need to process that game that
i had okay also i need to check out the shark too never mind
let me check out the guy this guy
i don't understand also i'm gonna dock your teammates too i
guess I don't understand why was it our game that you were
like this why was it why could you do this why why could you
do this before did this say celestial 2 was your career
highest oh my god what oh my oh my god Oh my god Okay, so
let's see what's his highest Okay Alright I'm a little
concerned I am just a little concerned But don't worry One
thing will always cheer me up
If all else fails I still have this bad But
okay the Jeff is on the enemy team now I am I'm this close
to batting Jeff I feel like which hero do you think you want
to be today I'm this close I feel like it'd be worth it it
might be worth it
we'll let them bat Jeff they recognize the name
ban daredevil first i'm gonna ban daredevil first
well they'll they'll ban daredevil first
oh fuck okay they banned gambit now what the fuck do i do i
just realized i haven't played gambit in a long ass time
life has been very cruel to me Life for some reason has been
very cruel.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Alright.
I shall go.
I deserve this game.
I don't know.
Like, where do I...
I'm going to rock it.
Fuck it.
I deserve a rocket game.
Oh, wait.
Jeff is still open.
Oh, my gosh.
I fucking zoned out.
It's okay.
We have Bucky and Matt.
We have Bucky at mag things will be okay
Okay, and we have star alert look at that things will be
five I believe I will not play Jeff I I will not play Jeff
right now.
I'm not in the right mindset anymore.
I'm not and definitely not in the right mindset The blade
Jeff There's no way they'll see it No yeah they will Put it
here There you go That'll be fine No ports right behind you
Why no cloak?
If they have mag I'm fucked I'm not trusting on that
Literally just Jesus Christ Oh my god I guess I'll just be
here I'm not getting high ground, I guess.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
They're not running triple support, so it's okay.
It's okay.
They're not running triple support, so it should be fine.
They're still not running.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
I gotta reload.
All right, here we go
There we go, see look at that Things are fine Things are so
fine I walk away now I Yeah Well I hope we have enough for
that Oh, that's awkward Goodbye invisible woman Goodbye Oh
my god Oh my god, okay, that's fine Sorry, me and my DPS
Okay, but Me and the deep, I told you.
I told you everything will be fine.
Me and the DPS.
Me and the DPS is holding the...
We're holding the fort.
We've held the fort.
I told you we'll hold the fort.
Wait, we'll put it here again.
I don't think they know.
What are you gonna do?
Go hog around?
Fucking crazy.
I leave.
Oh my god.
There we go.
See, I told you.
They're not gonna go high ground.
Look at that.
Alright.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Alright.
Watch.
Okay, I'm worried that when I say watch this, my entire team
will die.
So for now, we're gonna chill a little bit.
We're gonna chill a little bit.
And then...
This is real firepower!
Let's go!
Oh!
Ooh, okay.
Whoa!
Look at that!
I don't know...
Okay, I...
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
Everyone gets bubbled, you know?
It happens, it happens.
It happens.
Sometimes people just get bubbled.
It just happens.
Oh my god, okay.
Guys, don't worry.
They don't expect me in high ground.
They never expect the high ground.
Okay, Star Lord, I hope you live because I do not have any
more.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please do not touch me.
There you go.
See?
No one ever expects a rat on high ground.
Watch this again.
No one still expects a rat on high ground.
Look at that.
They're like, where's the beacon?
Surely it's not on high ground again.
True.
It's surely.
Oh my, it's okay.
It's okay.
I can heal myself.
You don't have to worry about me.
It's okay.
I can fend for myself.
Look at that.
I told you.
I'm gonna wait a little bit.
I'm gonna wait.
All right, all right.
All right.
We can kill him, right?
Okay.
Here we go.
I believe.
What did he got?
Oh, I still believe.
He just...
Okay.
He...
Oh!
Okay, I might have...
I should have altered earlier.
I thought...
I thought it was salvageable.
It was...
absolutely not salvageable i thought i thought i could save
them i really did i really did thought i could save them
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay you might be getting close but don't i need
you to know i tried so hard to heal you i really did i i
never I never stopped holding right click.
Like, there was nothing else I could do for this team.
Here we go.
This is real firepower.
Oh my god.
Oh, my god.
Oh.
Alright, so.
I should have altered earlier.
I did not think that...
That was going to have.
happen.
I stopped feeling.
You're right.
That was my biggest mistake.
I stopped feeling.
Okay, we're not putting that there.
We're gonna put... I thought I would hit the middle and it
would be like, oh, they're not gonna hit that.
It's in the middle, but...
Whoops.
Don't worry.
Boom!
They're not gonna find this, Rez.
Oh.
Let's...
Let's hope he hits.
He did not hit that.
Um...
Oh, okay, let's...
Don't worry, they don't see the rest.
You see that one beacon?
They all ran past it.
They're all actually running past it.
They actually don't see it.
Oh, thank God.
They don't see it.
That's the best part.
They don't know.
I don't...
That's very unlucky.
Oh, my God.
That's so unlucky.
That's so...
Oh, my.
I got it.
I'm just...
Oh my god, he's taking forever to kill me too.
Wait, they went triple support?
Okay, I am gonna swap.
I'm gonna swap after this.
I didn't even realize they went triple.
Fucking nerds.
Fucking course.
If all else fails, go triple support.
Always.
God damn it.
Fucking always.
Please don't let them shoot it.
Please protect our precious rock it up.
Guys, come on.
Protect the precious.
Aww.
It's okay.
We still have the Invisal.
We did it.
We did.
Alright, it's fine.
Everything is okay.
expect a flanking hella always what the fuck would hit me
told you they never expect it of course if all why don't i
why don't that happen to me oh pull back pull back my res is
so cool all right that is awkward because my res is so far i
would have have got the res i should have put the res closer
well maybe he gets res here he does okay that's good that's
good he does indeed get res there um oh well not for bucky
for bucky all right i'm going okay wait wait i could go look
here oh unless Um
All right, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have to relook.
I have All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
We got this Okay
All right Okay He has to pick me or there we go.
There we go.
There we go He doesn't see me.
He saw me, but there we go.
We have a res right here.
It's okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There we go!
Last minute pick!
Last minute!
Last minute.
I was right there.
We got the end pump.
I just turned around.
There we go.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh no.
No, no, no, it's the cop.
Literally just needed a copy.
Okay.
This is very unfortunate because we didn't get, bro.
We didn't get a lot of kills.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're on.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna go low key at this point.
I think we need the low key for the.
Yeah, yo, the stat line is not ideal.
I will say, the stat line is very sad to look at.
I felt like I did not see a GPS at all.
I really did not see it.
DPS stuff 30 seconds before you attack get ready Bucky ulted
but he was more like most like he was like sort of ulting
air It was like when I was playing Jeff that's how that's
how I felt watching that Bucky
And then I don't know what our other DPS was that's how
little of an impact I felt Like, I don't even remember.
I remember he was on Starlord.
What the fuck was he after that?
Like, what did he play after Starlord?
Oh my god.
Wait, they went.
Oh my god, please.
I am on.
Please, I am on.
I am on Loki.
Please, I am on low-key.
Like, this is very hard to aim in general.
Oh my god, please.
Please, oh!
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
We broke it.
I used Involve.
I don't think I should have but like I got really scared.
I
Please I am very scared Alright, nice Alright, that's good
Okay, nice.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Let's chill.
Let's just chill now.
I'll put you up here Alright, hot girl and I'll slowly push
the cart.
I believe in my team team all right no no no don't say that
don't jinx this guys don't you know don't jinx this don't
jinx this guys they're just gonna run the moment we jinx it
they're just gonna run triple support they're not the moment
we said anything they're just gonna run start running triple
support guys i do not want to with it okay i have to do that
because i want to make sure they live I suppose that helped.
I hope she's healing them back.
Um, share.
He is...
No.
Oh, my.
I don't think...
We were... Yeah.
You know that combo?
Yeah, no.
That was a really big combo I don't think it like I don't
even think like My Involve could have saved that that that
was seemed very hopeless
It really did
Are you serious Oh my god where three I have to use it I
have to use it okay oh my god I'm trying to get to my all
right oh my god we're triple we're triple let's go let's
there's hope
Oh, we're triple in that.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
There is hope in this world because we're triple.
Also, I need to get off.
Okay, Loki.
I forgot they're on moon night.
Oh, my God.
Is he okay?
Jesus Christ.
We're triple support!
It all else fails!
It like all else fails!
Triple support!
Here we go.
There we go.
It's the win condition.
It truly is the win condition.
Oh my.
Oh my god, okay, that's fine.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm scared.
I didn't want to get lay.
I had to use that because I got scared.
I got scared of fucking getting...
I got really scared.
I know I shouldn't have used it.
Oh my god, he's so...
He's alive!
I didn't want to use it, but like, he was gonna eat me
anyway.
I didn't want to waste it.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna try not to waste the next 12.
It sucked because, like, I hate trying to predict coffees.
It's so hard to predict for defensive up.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
I have to reload
It's okay guys What the fuck is going okay?
Okay, we can save her but that's the only one we can save
Nice
Oh my god
Please I'm trying my best.
Oh my this fight is I hate triple support.
Oh my god.
I hate triple support This fight is forever.
This
Goodbye This fight is lasting
Oh my god, this fight is actually lasting forever
Oh my god
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
Okay, okay.
This fight is still going on.
Where is my Invis?
Where is what's going on?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
The fight ended.
Oh, my God.
time to switch things up including which side you're on oh
my god the fight finally ended i i held my copy for as long
as i could
i guys i know they'll never do it but i hope one day they
will restrict the game so that you can only play two
supports.
I don't care anymore.
I really don't think I can keep on going in this game.
I don't know how much longer I have in me, but triple
support, I don't know how much longer.
I don't know how much I have left in me.
The triple support.
Oh my god.
Triple support is actually so hot so oh my I really hate
triple support so much It's just so broken It was a
three-minute team fight It was literally a three-minute team
fight You are restored I can be anyone
That's much better Okay.
Oh my god, I have this.
Oh my god, I have to drop down.
I hate this.
Oh my god.
Oh my!
I don't...
Okay.
It's fine.
I still have...
I have to reload.
Oh no.
What?
Oh no, oh no I have to read those
Oh my god, please
What to okay
That was everything.
That was literally everything.
All right.
Okay.
That was everything.
That was nearly everything.
Okay.
We have res.
We have res for the last fight.
They used so many else there.
That was very scary.
I was just like, okay.
Okay.
don't worry don't worry I do have I'm having rest by the way
sir you guys are down support the building the building
built up the building the bill oh my the the building
actually the building actually constructed itself that's
actually crazy like what what is the luck with that
oh my god oh my god how did that happen to me i can't have i
can't have shit in this game i i actually can't have
anything you'll need a top-notch team to win this one
that's actually crazy that's
of course the building constructs itself the moment that
happens
I don't know.
I'm just gonna go rocket for the res.
I just can't have anything.
Like, it's not allowed to have anything in this game.
I don't know.
Do I go rocket or Loki?
I can't tell.
I feel like Loki just for the amount of heals that I output.
Yeah, but I also played Loki during...
Attack.
Yeah, but I don't know if I should just swap rocket during
overtime.
Oh well, we'll find out.
We'll figure it out here.
I still can't believe that happened to me.
That is actually so unlucky.
Like, I actually can't have shit in this game.
Like, I'm not allowed to have, like, I'm not allowed to play
this game apparently.
which is crazy
um that was not a kick um excuse me where was my kick that I
was promised oh my god I'm gonna have to redo the rest soon
all right
Oh my Okay, I hope I hope he gets res here Nope Okay, I'm
gonna put the res closer then
Alright, let's hope that this does something Yeah
Oh, no, oh no Oh, no It's okay, it's okay it's okay oh my
god oh my god it's okay it's okay i am i'm spinning at orbs
out on you
okay now it's a little worrying now oh my god what the what
was she doing there okay there at least okay that's good I
was gonna say what oh my god Triple support hell triple
support hell actual triple support hell triple support hell
Oh my god, we don't have anything we don't have anything we
don't have anything we don't have anything I need to reload
I need to reload I need to reload I need to reload
Judge jury Okay, okay
All right, that's fine.
That's okay.
Oh.
All right.
All right, here you go.
I hope nothing shows up behind me.
Yeah, four, three.
I'm putting...
it here there is no way that there's no way that this will
get destroyed by construction there is there is no fucking
way literally all i'm doing i am i'm just chilling back here
oh my god you should get you should get res you should get
res you should get res thank god no oh no nothing god oh no
res is already oh no guys it's no longer thank god it's it's
no i need a reload i need a reload
it's no longer thank god right now it's no i'm stuck i'm I'm
stuck.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
And the moment fell into the hole.
I was like, I don't know what to do.
I'm in the hole.
I hope my team can see this.
Thank God.
Thank the Lord.
The tension was real.
Oh, my God.
See, wasn't that...
What an easy game.
Wow.
oh wow we oh plus 18 plus plus 18 plus 18 100 game blimey
through their parents of our take also the 100 100 as well
oh my god dude i will say this is the game i got lorded oh
don't oh my god are you kidding me congratulations donky
this This was the game you got, Lordin.
I deserve that.
Oh my god.
This is the game.
This was the game that I got, Lordin.
Because of course it is.
This Choppa.
Oh my god, Choppa is fucking...
Fucking thriving.
At least he's having a better time than me right now.
Oh my god.
fucking game isn't rocky your most hate bro what i have to
do during that game oh yeah sorry here's sorry to front view
back view guys i know i you're like you have to use the
bathroom guys you understand i've been all i've been doing
is drinking water play rivals okay this will be my lg
because i think i'm at my limit that game took 20 years off
my life's bad.
But I'll make one more LG.
Guys, this will be my LG, guys.
I'll be right back.
I go pee.
Last game.
I'll do one last game.
The last game to end it all.
I don't.
You're gonna spend time square for the last game.
I did not expect myself to stream seven hours, but I've been
having fun.
I've been having a lot of fun.
You know what?
Let's go party with the lunas.
Hello, I'll be here.
In the center.
Don't worry, your backup dancer is here.
Let's enjoy the show, everyone.
Yay!
All because two guys were really mean to me.
you should thank them I wouldn't she's streaming right now
just because those two people were mean to me and now I'm
here for seven hours thank
you to the two random dudes now who am I gonna banish from
this match so I was in this place Or are we banning?
Happy birthday!
Okay, I'll trust my...
I'll trust my players to do the bans.
Also, most likely I won't raid anyone.
I'm just gonna fucking free you guys into the spear.
But you guys just got dispersed because I'm too tired to...
I'm too tired to, like, figure it out.
I mean, I'm tempted to banja.
You guys just guys just go into the void.
Oh, I'm getting all bad side lock.
Emma, alright.
I mean, we don't have an Emma player right now.
Or is it going to go in my nose?
I'll be back.
Or villain, I'm not judging.
Alright, so this is going to be the last game I end this on.
Alright.
This will be the last game, I guess.
No matter what happens, I'm ending it on this game Oh, thank
God at least it's cough So guys, the best thing about it is
that it's Oh my god, my fucking rocket Oh my god, I look
like a rocket one trick now
Oh my god, I don't like it at all Guys, it makes me very
uncomfortable
all right here we go this will work i believe i am i have a
team up with two of these people unfortunately our widow
doesn't have a phoenix team up so i don't know all right we
only have rocky holes yep good observation bro
very good observation guys catch it the orb oh my god it's
okay catch the orb yeah oh but they have jeff's solo heels
oh there is a guy please other team have bigger egos than my
team please that's all i want just have a bigger ego
compared to my team please oh my god i that's all i want as
long as you have a bigger egos than my team, then it should
be fine.
Bro, okay, you gotta remember.
I, you got...
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
Your only support is dead.
Okay, I'm not gonna...
I didn't realize Rocket died.
Yeah, I got fucking...
I'm not, I'm not.
We only have Rocket heals.
Don't worry.
Chuck!
Don't worry, I chucked it.
They only have Jeffhills, so it balances out, guys.
Oh, they only have Jeff.
Oh, my God.
Please, please don't let them do this to me, please.
Please don't let them do this to me.
Please, they only have Jeffhills.
They only have Jeffhills.
I'll just stay here.
Please.
I'll...
They don't have defensive ults.
Please, have a bigger ego.
Have a bigger...
okay i'll protect your rocket okay okay okay don't let him
come to me you're gonna have silent i can't protect you
anymore i'm sorry no
It's not fair
What do you mean they have someone that's willing to swap
Okay, there is nothing I could do there What do you mean?
This please Captain America this is your only hope yeah,
you're all is Oh my gosh, if you die don't worry if you die.
I also have a fucking res here.
Oh, we did it.
Yeah, let's go
Okay, okay, this is okay.
Holy shit, I've included.
This guy fucking goes, welcome to Marvel Rival.
Like all day, it's like, oh my god, it's that egg strike on
our team.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Wait, where did my thing go?
30 seconds before you...
Where the fuck did my thing go?
okay there you go happy birthday happy birthday i was like
what happened to my thing okay it's fine i'm so upset that
they their egos were smaller than our egos i'm so sad turf
is like chicken and like i'm so sad or fish with some like
rice this is not fair two supports and like two real takes
this is messed up this is so messed up i should be allowed
to also i'm so scared i'm so scared oh okay okay nice happy
birthday whoa wow wow wow okay happy birthday i'm alive i'm
alive we're alive it's okay it's okay i'm gonna okay guys
guys guys guys guys guys guys don't let this happen to me
don't guys guys guys oh thank thank god we have captain
america thank god this
Guys And
the spider-man lives Okay, oh Okay, okay, buddy.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, all right.
That's cool.
We didn't kill the Spider-Man in the end.
That is my favorite part, knowing that.
Knowing that.
Okay.
I'm gonna destroy this.
And then...
And then I know I'm not gonna live.
but maybe my team will be oh no my team did not do it oh
wait wait unless unless unless it's okay it's okay I'm
coming over it's okay it's okay Chuck it's okay this should
rest one of them yes it didn't rest one of them but But like
it's the thought that counts Guys, I don't want to be here
anymore It is not fair that they are allowed to have two
supports And like this is not fair.
I demand a bodyguard Uh-oh Uh-oh Uh-oh Okay Okay Okay Okay
Okay Okay Okay, everything is fine.
This is the place.
I'm Rito Frito one.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
I'm fucking standing on the web.
The web is my heal.
Okay.
It's okay.
Okay, it's okay.
I it's okay.
It's not.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It is it is absolutely winnable.
Oh my god He's fucking he's fucking right now.
He is absolute Chuck Okay, all right.
There you go All right Oh my god, you were our other support
you were our other support.
What do you mean?
Why did you use this for yourself?
I won.
I that's fine I
see easy I'll take it what a game to end on I'll take that
just the enemy team just happened to be so much more worse
than us thank fucking god thank god
thank the lord thank you at least they're actually thank god
I told my god I'm just oh plus 16 I was the only support
what do you mean plus 16 I stole my oh oh my god for what I
had to go through okay that's fine I'll take it thank you I
won't through so much abuse today uh solo support i think
the the game should recognize that i was by myself and then
give me like plus 50 for what i had to go through what
what i had to go through that was insane hey guys i'm
calling here i said it was the lg no might a winner or loss.
That was a fucking wild day.
Wild stream today.
I was fighting for my fucking life there.
Those are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but today I did a gorilla
stream, like an impromptu stream on Twitch.
So you want to know, so you want to see more of my content.
Please feel free to check me out on YouTube.
That's where I do most of my streams.
Twitter.
That's when I announce whenever I'm streaming on Twitter
because I did that like five in the morning.
I'd be like, hey guys, I'm gonna stream at five in the
morning.
If you're right, I'm gonna sleep yet.
I'm gonna sleep after.
I'm definitely gonna sleep now after this.
It's like 12 p.m.
now.
Um, and what else?
What else?
Uh, yeah, someone support me via other means.
I have merch.
So please check out my merch.
Um, please check out my merch.
It really does help out a lot supporting me and my streams.
Um, and yeah, that should be everything.
Uh, blah, blah, blah.
But yeah, thank you all for the donations, for the bitties,
for the subs, uh, for all the raids i really do appreciate
it i hope you guys have enjoyed another uh tormenting day of
marvel rivals that's quite that's that's cool i didn't
realize i was like i was apparently like the top for marvel
rivals like the entire time when i streamed so thank you
guys thank you all so much for the support i'm glad you've
been enjoying uh these streams it has been very very fun um
i'm gonna head out now um i'm not gonna i'm just gonna
fucking send you out into the world you guys burst into
wherever you guys want to go because i'm tired uh i don't
want to make choices anymore you guys just go wherever you
want to go hey guys bye everyone as always everybody say
hydrated posture check you ever move around to get that
blood flowing and you stay up for me head to bed cause you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys bye
and even though i lost more than i gained like you know what
like it's fine like that's that's just marvel rivals
say that some of the games that were given to me like on
stream was so like it was not winnable like i will say it
was not my fault for some of those games like they were they
were absolute there's nothing in the world like god cannot
save my team
God cannot save my team in a lot of those games Anyway guys,
I'll see you guys next time everyone Bye guys, bye Like if
God fucking took over one of my players Like he would still
lose It was impossible because it would still be a 5v6
Because we would have a Mr. Fantastic Anyway
And I got I'll get it.
Anyway, I'll get back Celestia too.
I'm just like so close.
See, I'll get back Celestia too.
Like, I mean Playing on at this time playing at five in the
morning.
It's not about climbing.
We all know that Like when if we do climb, it's a lovely
surprise So so like like like like I know queuing this time
was not for climbing.
It's just a vibe And to suffer together.
Anyway guys, I'll see you guys later everyone.
Bye guys.
Bye Bye!